the following is a conversation with
jeff hawkins a neuroscientist
seeking to understand the structure
function
and origin of intelligence in the human
brain he previously wrote the seminal
book on the subject
titled on intelligence and recently
a new book called a thousand brains
which presents a new theory of
intelligence
that richard dawkins for example has
been
raving about calling the book quote
brilliant and exhilarating
i can't read those two words and not
think of him saying it in his british
accent
quick mention of our sponsors codecademy
bio optimizers
expressvpn a-sleep and blinkist check
them out in the description to support
this podcast
as a side note let me say that one small
but powerful idea that jeff hawkins
mentions in his new book
is that if human civilization were to
destroy itself
all of knowledge all our creations will
go with
us he proposes that we should think
about how to save that knowledge
in a way that long outlives us whether
that's on earth
in orbit around earth or in deep space
and then to send messages that advertise
this backup of human knowledge
to other intelligent alien civilizations
the main message of this advertisement
is not
that we are here but that we were
once here this little difference
somehow was deeply humbling to me that
we may
with some non-zero likelihood destroy
ourselves and that an alien civilization
thousands or millions of years from now
may come across this knowledge store
and they would only with some low
probability
even notice it not to mention be able to
interpret it
and the deeper question here for me is
what information in all of human
knowledge is even essential
does wikipedia capture it or not at all
this thought experiment
forces me to wonder what are the things
we've accomplished
and are hoping to still accomplish that
will outlive us
is it things like complex buildings
bridges cars
rockets is it ideas like science physics
and mathematics
is it music and art is it
computers computational systems or even
artificial intelligence systems
i personally can't imagine that aliens
wouldn't already have
all of these things in fact much more
and much better to me the only unique
thing we may have
is consciousness itself and the actual
subjective experience of suffering
of happiness of hatred of love
if we can record these experiences in
the highest resolution directly from the
human brain
such that aliens will be able to replay
them that
is what we should store and send as a
message
not wikipedia but the extremes of
conscious experiences
the most important of which of course is
love
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation
with jeff hawkins we previously
talked over two years ago do you think
there's still neurons in your brain
that uh remember that conversation that
uh remember me
and got excited like there's a lex
neuron in your brain that just like
finally has a purpose
i do remember our conversation or i have
some memories of it
and i formed additional memories of you
in the meantime
um i wouldn't say there's a neuron or a
neurons in my brain that know you
there are synapses in my brain that have
formed
that reflect my knowledge of you and the
model i have of you in the world and
whether the exact same synapses were
formed two years ago it's hard to say
because these things come and go all the
time but
we know from one thing to know about
brains is that when you think of things
you often erase the memory and rewrite
it again so
yes but i have a memory of you and i
have that's instantiated in synapses
there's a simpler way to think about it
like so you have we have a model
of the world in your head and that model
is continually being updated
i updated this morning you offered me
this water you said it was from the
refrigerator
i remember these things and so we and so
the model includes where we live the
places we know the words the
objects in the world it's a monstrous
model and it's constantly being updated
and people are just part of that model
so we're animals or other physical
objects
so our events we've done so um
it's there's no special in my mind
special place for the memories of humans
i mean
obviously i know you know i know a lot
about my wife
um but and friends uh and so on but
it's not like a special place for humans
over here but we model everything and we
model other people's behaviors too so if
i said you're a
copy of your mind in my mind it's just
because i know how humans
i've learned how humans behave and um
and i've learned some things about you
and that's part of my world model well i
just also mean
the collective intelligence of the human
species
i wonder if there's something
fundamental to the brain that enables
that so modeling other humans with their
ideas
you're actually jumping into a lot of
big topics like collective intelligence
is a separate topic that a lot of people
like to talk about we can talk about
that
uh but um and so that's interesting like
you know we're not just individuals we
live in society and so on
but from our research point of view and
so again let's just talk
we study the neocortex it's a sheet of
neural tissue it's about 75
of your brain it runs on this very
repetitive algorithm
it's a very repetitive circuit and so
you can apply that algorithm to lots of
different problems but it's all
underneath it's the same thing we're
just building this model
so from our point of view we wouldn't
look for these special circuit someplace
buried in your brain that might be
related to
other you know understanding of the
humans it's more like
you know how do we build a model of
anything how do we understand anything
in the world and humans are just
another part of the things we understand
so there's nothing uh there's nothing to
the brain that
knows the emergent phenomena of
collecting the intelligence well i
certainly know about that i've heard the
terms i've read
no but that's right right well okay
right as an idea well i think we have
language which is is
sort of built into our brains and that's
a key part of collective intelligence so
there are some you know prior
assumptions about the world we're going
to live in when we're born we're not
just
a blank slate um and so you know did we
evolve
to take advantage of those situations
yes but again
we study only part of the brain the
neocortex there's other parts of the
brain are very much
involved in societal interactions and
human emotions and
um and how we interact and even societal
um
issues about you know how we are how we
interact with other people when we
support them when we're greedy and
things like that i mean certainly the
brain
is a great place where to study
intelligence i wonder if it's the
fundamental
uh atom of intelligence well i would say
it's
it's it's absolutely an essential
component even if you believe in
collective intelligence as
um hey that's where it's all happening
that's what we need to study which i
don't believe that by the way i think
it's really important but i don't think
that is the thing
um but even if you do believe that then
you have to understand how the brain
works in doing that
um it's you know it's more like we are
intelligent and
we are intelligent individuals and
together we are much more magnified our
intelligence we can do things that we
couldn't do individually
but even as individuals we're pretty
damn smart and
we can model things and understand the
world and interact with it
so um to me if you're going to start
some place you need to start
with the brain then you could say well
how do brains interact with each other
and what is the nature of language and
how do we
share models that i've learned something
about the world how do i share it with
you which is really what you know
sort of communal intelligence is i know
something you know something
we've had different experiences in the
world i've learned something about
brains maybe i can impart that to you
you've learned something about
you know whatever physics and you can
part that to me
but it also comes down to even just the
epistemological question of
well what is knowledge and how do you
represent it in the brain right
and it's not that's where it's going to
reside right or in our writings
it's obvious that human collaboration
human interaction
is how we build societies right but some
of the things you
talk about and work on
some of those elements of what makes up
an intelligent
entity is there with a single person oh
absolutely i mean
it'd be we can't deny that the brain is
the core element here in
in uh at least i can't i think it's
obvious the brain is the core element in
all theories of intelligence
uh it's where knowledge is represented
it's where knowledge is created
we interact we share we build upon each
other's work
but uh without a brain you'd have
nothing you know there would be no
intelligence without brains
and so um so that's where we start
i got into this field because i just was
curious as to who i am
you know how you know how do i think
what's going on in my head when i'm
what i'm thinking what does it mean to
know something you know i can ask what
it means for me to know something
independent of how i learned it from
you or from someone else or from society
so what does it mean for me to know that
i have a model of you in my head what
does it mean to know i know what this
microphone does and how it works
physically even though i can't see it
right now
how do i know that what does it mean how
the neurons do that at the
fundamental level of neurons and
synapses and so on those are
really fascinating questions and uh i'm
happy to
be just happy to understand those if i
could
so in your um in your new book
you talk about our brain our mind as
being made up of many brains
uh so the book is called the thousand
brains a thousand brain theory of
intelligence what is the key idea of
this book
uh the book has three sections
and it has sort of maybe three big ideas
so the first section is all about what
we've learned about the neurocortex and
that's the thousand brains theory
just did we complete the picture the
second section is all about ai and the
third section is about the future of
humanity
so the thousand brains theory
the the big idea there if i had to
summarize into one big idea
is that we think of the the brain the
neocortex is learning this model of the
world
but what we learned is actually there's
tens of thousands of independent
modeling systems going on and so each
what we call a column in the cortex is
about 150
000 of them is a complete modeling
system so
it's a collective intelligence in your
head in some sense so the thousand
brains theory says
well where do i have knowledge about you
know this coffee cup where is the model
of this
cell phone it's not in one place it's in
thousands of separate models that are
complementary and they communicate
with each other through voting so this
idea that we have we feel like we're one
person
you know that's our experience we can
explain that but reality there's
lots of these like almost like little
brands like but they're
they're sophisticated modeling systems
about 150 000 of them in each of
the human brain and that's a totally
different way of thinking about
how the neural cortex is structured than
we or anyone else thought of even just
five years ago
so you mentioned you started this
journey
and just looking in the mirror trying to
understand who you are
so if you have many brains who are you
then
so it's interesting we have a singular
perception right you know we think oh
i'm just
here i'm looking at you but it's it's
composed of all these things like
there's sounds and there's
and there's uh this vision and there's
touch and
all kinds of inputs yeah we have the
singular perception and what the
thousand brain theory says we have these
models that are visual models we have a
lot of models of auditory models models
of toxin models and so on
but they vote and so um they send in the
cortex you can think about these columns
as that like little grains of
rice 150 000 stacked next to each other
and each one is its own little modeling
system
but they have these long-range
connections that go between them
and we call those voting connections or
voting neurons
um and so the different columns
try to reach the consensus like what am
i looking at okay you know
each one has some ambiguity but they
come to a consensus oh there's a water
bottle i'm looking at
um we are only consciously able to
perceive the voting
we're not able to perceive anything that
goes on under the hood
so the voting is what we're we're aware
of
the results of the vote yeah the
velocity well it's it's you can imagine
it this way
we were just talking about eye movements
a moment ago so as i'm looking at
something my eyes are moving about three
times a second
and with each movement a completely new
input is coming into the brain it's not
repetitive it's not shifting it around
it's completely new
i'm totally unaware of it i can't
perceive it but yet if i looked at the
neurons in your brain they're going on
and off i don't know
but the voting neurons are not the
voting neurons are saying you know
we all agree even though i'm looking at
different parts of this is a water
bottle right now
and that's not changing and it's in some
position and
and pose relative to me so i have this
perception of the water bottle about two
feet away from me at a certain pose to
me
um that is not changing that's the only
part i'm aware of i can't be aware of
the fact that the inputs
from the eyes are moving and changing
and all this others happening
so these long range connections are the
part we can be conscious of
the individual activity in each column
is doesn't go anywhere else it doesn't
get shared anywhere else it doesn't
there's no way to extract it
and talk about it or extract it and even
remember it to say oh
yes i can recall that um so but these
long-range connections are the things
that are accessible to language
and to our you know it's like the
hippocampus or our memories you know
our short-term memory systems and so on
so we're not aware of
95 or maybe it's even 98 of what's going
on in your brain
we're only aware of this sort of stable
somewhat stable
voting outcome of all these things that
are going on underneath the hood
so what would you say is the basic
element in the thousand
brains theory of intelligence of
intelligence
like what's the atom of intelligence
when you think about it
is it the individual brains and then
what is a brain
well let's let's can we just talk about
what intelligence is first
and then and then we can talk about the
elements are so in my
in my book intelligence is the ability
to learn
a model of the world so to build
internal to your head
a model that represents the structure of
everything you know
to know what this is a table and that's
a coffee cup and this is a gooseneck
lamp and all this
to know these things i have to have a
model in my head i just don't look at
them and go what is that
i already have internal representations
of these things in my head
and i had to learn them i wasn't born of
any of that knowledge
you were you know we have some lights in
the room here i you know that's not part
of my evolutionary heritage right it's
not in my genes
so um we have this incredible model and
the model includes not only what things
look like and feel like but where they
are relative to each other and how they
behave
i've never picked up this water bottle
before but i know that if i took my hand
on that blue thing and i turn it it'll
probably make a funny little sound as
the little plastic things detach
and then it'll rotate and it'll look a
certain way it'll come off how do i know
that right because i have this model in
my head
so the essence of intelligence as our
ability to learn a model and the more
sophisticated our model is
the smarter we are not that there is a
single intelligence because
you can know about you know a lot about
things that i don't know and i know
about things you don't know
and we can both be very smart but we
both learn the model of the world
through interacting with it
so that is the essence of intelligence
then we can ask ourselves what are the
mechanisms in the brain
that allow us to do that and what are
the mechanisms of learning not just the
neural mechanisms what is the general
process but how we learn a model
so that was a big insight for us it's
like what are the what is the actual
things that how do you learn this stuff
it turns out you have to learn it
through movement
um you can't learn it just by that's how
we learn we learn through movement we
learn
um so you build up this model by
observing things and touching them and
moving them and
walking around the world and so on so
either you move or the thing moves
somehow yeah you obviously can learn
things just by reading a book something
like that but
think about if i were to say oh here's a
new house yeah i want you to learn
you know what do you do you have to walk
you have to walk from room to the room
you have to open the doors
look around see what's on the left
what's on the right as you do this
you're building a model in your head
it's just that's what you're doing you
can't just sit there and say i'm going
gonna grock the house
no you know or you could you don't even
want to sit there and read some
description of it right
yeah you literally physically
interactive the same with like a
smartphone if i want to
learn a new app i touch it and i move
things around i see what happens when i
when i do things with it so that's the
basic way we learn in the world and by
the way when you say model
you mean something that can be used for
prediction in the future
it's it's used for prediction and for
behavior
and planning right um and does a pretty
good job in doing so
yeah here's the way to think about the
model a lot of people get hung up on
this so
um you can imagine an architect making a
model of a house
right so there's a physical model that's
small and why do they do that
well we do that because you can imagine
what it would look like from different
angles you could say okay
look at them here look in there and you
can also say well how how far to get
from
from the garage to the to the swimming
pool or something like that right you
can imagine looking at this you can say
what would be the view from this
location so we built these physical
models to let you
imagine the future and imagine that
behaviors
now we can take that same model and put
it in a computer so we now
today they'll build models of houses and
a computer and they
and they do that using a set of um
we'll come back to this term in a moment
reference frames but eventually you
assign a reference frame for the house
and you assign different things for the
house in different locations
and then the computer can generate an
image and say okay this is what it looks
like in this direction
the brain is doing something remarkably
similar to this surprising
um it's using reference frames it's
building these it's similar to a model
in a computer
which has the same benefits of building
a physical model it allows me to say
what would this thing
look like if it was in this orientation
what would likely happen if i push this
button
i've never pushed this button before or
how would i accomplish something i want
to
i want to um convey a new idea i've
learned
how would i do that i can imagine in my
head well i could talk about it
i could write a book i could do some
podcasts
i could um you know maybe tell my
neighbor
you know and i can imagine the outcomes
of all these things before i do any of
them
that's what the model lets you do it
let's just plan the future and imagine
the
consequences of our actions prediction
you asked about prediction
prediction is not the goal of the model
prediction is an inherent property of it
and it's how the model corrects itself
so prediction is fundamental to
intelligence
it's fundamental to building a model and
the model's intelligent
and let me go back and be very precise
about this prediction you can think of
prediction two ways one is like
hey what would happen if i did this
that's the type of prediction um
that's a key part of intelligence but
using predictions like oh what's this
this is this water bottle gonna feel
like when i pick it up
you know and that doesn't seem very
intelligent but the way to think one way
to think about intelligence prediction
is
it's a way for us to learn where our
model is wrong
so if i picked up this water bottle and
it felt hot i'd be very surprised
or if i picked up was very light it
would be very i'd be surprised or
if i turned this top and it didn't i had
to turn the other way i'd be surprised
and so almost might have a prediction
like okay i'm gonna do it i'll drink
some water
i'm okay okay do this there it is i feel
opening right what if i had to turn it
the other way or what if it it split in
two
then i say oh my gosh i i misunderstood
this i didn't have the right model of
this thing
my attention would be drawn to i'll be
looking at it going well how the hell
did that happen
you know why did it open up that way and
i would update my model
by doing it just by looking at it and
playing around with that update and say
this is a new type of water bottle
but you so you're talking about sort of
uh
complicated things like a water bottle
but this also applies for just
basic vision just like seeing things
it's almost like a precondition of just
perceiving the world is predicting
it's just everything that you see is
first passed through your prediction
everything you
see and feel in fact this this is the
insight i had
uh back in the late 80s uh and excuse me
early 80s
and um another people reach the same
idea is that
every sensory input you get not just
vision but touch
and hearing you have an expectation
about it
and um a prediction sometimes you can
pick very accurately sometimes you can't
i can't predict what next word is going
to come out of your mouth but as you
start talking about
better and better predictions and if you
talk about some topics i'd be very
surprised
so i have this sort of background
prediction that's going on all the time
for all my senses again the way i think
about that
is this is how we learn it's it's more
about how we learn
it's the test of our understanding our
predictions are our test
did is this really a water bottle if it
is i shouldn't see
you know a little finger sticking out
the side and if i saw a little finger
stick and i was like what the hell is
going on
you know that's not normal um i mean
that's
fascinating that just let me linger on
this
for a second i it really honestly feels
that prediction is fundamental
to everything uh to the way our mind
operates
to intelligence so like it's just a
different way to see
intelligence which is like everything
starts at prediction
and prediction requires a model you
can't predict something unless you have
a model of it right but the action is
prediction it's like the
the thing the model does is prediction
and but it also yeah and you but
you can then extend it to things like uh
what would happen
if i took this today i went and did this
what would be like that
or how you can extend predictions like
oh i want to get a promotion at work
um what action should i take and you can
say if i did this i predict what might
happen if i
spoke to someone i predict what might
happen so it's not just low level
predictions yeah it's all prediction
it's all predictions like this
black box so you can ask basically any
question low level or highlight so we
start off with that observation it's all
it's like this non-stop prediction and i
write about this in the book about
and then we ask how do neurons actually
make predictions
physically like what does the neuron do
when it makes a prediction and
um what the neural tissue does when it
makes predictions and then we ask what
are the mechanisms by how we build a
model that allows you to make prediction
so we started with prediction as sort of
the fundamental
research agenda if in some sense like
and say well we understand how the brain
makes predictions
we'll understand how it builds these
models and how it learns and that's core
of intelligence so it was like it was
the key that got us in the door
to say that is our research agenda
understand predictions
so in this whole process where does
intelligence
originate would you say so
it if we look at things that are
much less intelligent to humans and you
start to build up a human the process of
evolution
where is this magic thing that uh
has a prediction model or a model that's
able to predict
that starts to look a lot more like
intelligence is there a place where
richard dawkins wrote an introduction to
your uh to your book an excellent
introduction
i mean it puts a lot of things into
context
and it's funny just looking at parallels
for your book and
darwin's origin of species so darwin
wrote about the origin
of species so
what is the origin of intelligence well
we have a theory about it and it's just
that it's a theory
theory goes as follows as soon as living
things
started to move they're not just
floating in sea they're not just
a plant you know grounded some place as
soon as they started the move
there was an advantage to moving
intelligently to moving in certain ways
and there's some very simple things you
can do you know bacteria or
single cell organisms can move towards a
source of gradient of food or something
like that
but an animal that might know where it
is and know where it's been and how to
get back to that place or an animal that
might
say oh there was a source of food
someplace how do i get to it or there
was a
danger how do i get to there was a mate
how do i get to them
um there was a big evolution advantage
to that so early on there was a pressure
to start
understanding your environment like
where am i
and where have i been and what happened
in those different places
so we still have this neural mechanism
in our brains um it's in in the in the
mammals it's in the
hippocampus and internal cortex these
are older parts of the brain
um and these are very well studied um
we build a map of the of our environment
so
these neurons in these parts of the
brain know where i am in this room and
where
the door was and things like that so a
lot of other
mammals have this all mammals have this
right and almost
any any animal that knows where it is
and get around must have some mapping
system must have some way of saying
i've learned a map of my environment i
have hummingbirds in my backyard and
they
and they go the same places all the time
they have to they must know where they
are they just know where they are when
they're
they're not just randomly flying around
they know they know particular flowers
they come back to
so we all have this and it turns out
it's
very tricky to get neurons to do this to
build a map of an environment it's just
and so we now know there's this these
famous studies that's still very active
about
place cells and grid cells and these
other types of cells in the older parts
of the brain
and how they build these maps of the
world it's really clever it's obviously
been under a lot of evolutionary
pressure over a long period of time to
get good at this
so animals not know where they are what
we think has happened
uh and there's a lot of evidence to
digest this is that that mechanism we
learn to map
like a space is
was repackaged the same type of neurons
was repackaged into a more compact form
and that became the cortical column and
it was
it was in some sense genericized if
that's a word it was turned into a very
specific thing about learning
maps of environments to learning maps of
anything
learning a model of anything not just
your space but coffee cups and so on
and it got sort of repackaged
into a more compact version a more
universal version
and then replicate it so the reason
we're so flexible is we have a very
generic version of this
mapping algorithm and we have 150 000
copies of it
sounds a lot like the progress of deep
learning
how so uh so take neural networks that
seem to work well for a specific task
compress them and multiply it
by a lot and then you just stack them on
top of it it's like the story of
transformers and uh yeah
but interesting networks they end up
you're replicating an element but you
still need the entire network to do
anything
right here what what's going on each
individual element is a complete
learning system
this is why i can take a human brain cut
it in half and it still works
it's it's pretty amazing it's
fundamentally distributed it's
fundamentally distributed complete
modeling systems
so but that's that's our story we like
to tell
i i i would guess it's it's likely
largely right um but you know it's
there's a lot of evidence supporting
that story this evolutionary story
the thing which brought me to this idea
is that the human brain
got big very quickly so that that
led to the proposal a long time ago that
well there's this common element just
instead of
creating new things it just replicated
something we also are extremely flexible
we can learn things that we had no
history about right and so that tells it
that the
learning algorithm is very generic it's
very kind of universal
because it's it doesn't assume any prior
knowledge about what it's learning
and so you combine those things together
and you say okay well how did that come
about where did that universal algorithm
come from it had to come from something
that wasn't universal it came from
something that was more specific
and so anyway this led to our hypothesis
that you would find grid cells and place
cell equivalents in the neocortex
and when we first published our first
papers on this theory
we didn't know of evidence for that it
turns out there was some but we didn't
know about it
uh and since then um so then we became
aware of evidence for grid cells in
parts of the neural cortex
and then now there's been new evidence
coming out there's some
interesting papers that came out just
january of this year so our one of our
predictions was
if this evolutionary hypothesis is
correct we would see grid cell place
cell equivalents cells that work like
them
through every column in the near cortex
and that's starting to be seen
what does it mean that uh why is it
important that they're present
because it tells us well we're asking
about the evolutionary origin of
intelligence right
so our theory is that these columns in
the cortex
are working on the same principles
they're modeling systems and it's hard
to imagine how neurons do this and so we
said
hey it's really hard to imagine how
neurons could learn these models of
things
we can talk about the details of that if
you want but
let's um but there's this other part of
the brain we know that learns models of
environments so could that mechanism to
learn to model this room be used to
learn a model the water bottle
is it the same mechanism so we said it's
much more likely the brain is using the
same mechanism
which case it would have these
equivalent cell types
so it's basically the whole theory is
built on the idea that
um these columns have reference frames
and they're learning these models
and these these grid cells create these
reference frames so it's it's basically
the major in some sense the major
predictive
part of this theory is that we will find
these equivalent mechanisms in
each column in the near cortex which
tells us that's that
that that's what they're doing they're
learning these sensory motor models
of the world so just we're pretty
confident
that would happen but now we're seeing
the evidence so the evolutionary process
nature does a lot of copy and paste and
see what happens yeah
yeah there's no direction to it but but
um it just found out like hey if i
took this these elements and and made
more of them what happens and let's hook
them up to the eyes and let's look up
the ears and
and um and that seems to work pretty
well yeah like for us
again just to take a quick step back to
our
conversation of collective intelligence
do you sometimes
see that as just another copy and paste
aspect is copying pasting these uh
brains and
humans and making a lot of them and then
creating
uh social structures that then almost
operates as a single brain
uh i wouldn't have said it but you said
it sounded pretty good
so to you the brain is fundamental is uh
is like uh
is its own thing right i mean our goal
is to understand how the neural cortex
works
we can argue how essential that is to
understand a human brain because it's
not the entire human brain
you can argue how essential that is to
understanding human intelligence
you can argue how essential it is to um
to uh you know a sort of communal
intelligence
um i i'm not i didn't our goal was to
understand the neocortex yeah so what is
the neural cortex and where does it fit
in um the various aspects of what the
brain does
like how important is it to you well
obviously
again we i mentioned again in the
beginning it's it's it's
about 70 to 75 of the volume of a human
brain
so it's you know it dominates our brain
in terms of size not in terms of number
of neurons but
in terms of size size isn't everything
jeff
i know but it's it's nothing it's
nothing
it's not that we know that all
high-level vision
hearing and touch happens in the air
context we know that all language
occurs and is understood in the
neurocortex whether that's spoken
language written language sign language
with
language of mathematics language of
physics music
math you know we know that all
high-level planning and thinking occurs
in the new york cortex
if i were to say you know what part of
your brain designed a computer
and understands programming and and
creates music it's all the neural cortex
so then that's kind of undeniable fact
uh if but then there's other parts of
our brain are important too
right our emotional states uh our body
regulating our body
um so the way i like to look at it is
you know could you can you understand
the neocortex about the rest of the
brain
and some people say you can't and i
think absolutely you can
it's not that they're not interacting
but you can understand them can you
understand the neocortex without
understanding the emotions of fear yes
you can you can understand how the
system works it's just a modeling system
i make the analogy in the book that it's
it's like a map of the world
and how that map is used depends on
who's using it
so how our map of our world in our
neocortex
how we how we manifest as a human
depends on the rest of our brain what
are our motivations you know what are my
desires am i a nice guy or not a nice
guy
am i a cheater or a you know or not a
cheater um
uh you know how important different
things are in my life
so um so but the
new projects can be understood on its
own um and and i say that
as a neuroscientist i know there's all
these interactions and i want to
say i don't know them and we don't think
about them but from a layperson's point
of view you can say
it's a modeling system i don't tend to
think too much about the communal aspect
of intelligence which you brought a
number of times already
um so that's not really been my concern
i just wonder if there's a continuum
from the origin of the universe like
this com pockets of complexities that
form
yeah living organisms i wonder if if
we're just
if you look at humans we feel like we're
at the top
but i wonder if there's like just where
everybody probably every living type
pocket of complexity
is probably thinks they're the uh pardon
the french
they're the yeah they're they're
they're at the top of the parent well
if they're thinking um well then then
what is thinking what the all right
in this sense the whole point is in
their
sense of the world they their sense
is that they're at the top of it i think
what is it turtle
but you're you're you're bringing up you
know the the problems of complexity and
complexity theory
are you know it's a huge interesting
problem in science
um and you know i think we've made
surprisingly little progress in
understanding complex systems
right in general um and so you know the
santa fe institute was founded to to
study this and and even the scientists
there will say it's really hard we
haven't really been able to figure out
exactly you know that science isn't
really congealed yet we're still trying
to figure out the basic elements of that
science
uh what you know where does complexity
come from and what is it and how you
define it whether it's
dna creating bodies or phenotypes or if
it's
individuals creating societies or ants
and you know
markets and so on it's it's a very
complex thing i'm not a complexity
theorist
person right um and i i think
they ask well the brain itself is a
complex system so
can we understand that um i think we've
made a lot of progress understanding how
the brain works
so but i haven't brought it out to like
oh well where are we on the complexity
spectrum
you know it's like um that's a great
question
i'd prefer for that answer to be we're
not special
it seems like if we're honest most
likely we're not special so if there is
a spectrum
we're probably not in some kind of
significant place there's one thing we
could say that we are special
and and again only here on earth i'm not
saying i'm bad
is that if we think about knowledge
what we know um we clearly
human brains have um the only brains
that have a certain types of knowledge
we're the only brains on
on this earth to understand uh what the
earth is how old it is
that the universe is a picture as a
whole the only organisms understand dna
and the origins of you know of species
uh no other species on on this planet
has that
knowledge so if we think about i like to
think about
you know one of the endeavors of
humanity is to
understand the universe as much as we
can um
i think our species is further along in
that undeniably
um whether our theories are right or
wrong we can debate but at least we have
theories you know we
we know that what the sun is and how
it's fusion is and how
what black holes are and you know we
know
general theory relativity and no other
animal has any of this knowledge
so in that sense that we're special uh
are we special in terms of
the the hierarchy of complexity in in
the universe probably not
can we look at a neuron yeah you say
that prediction
happens in the neuron what does that
mean so neuron traditionally seen as the
basic element
of the the brain so we i mentioned this
earlier
that prediction was our research agenda
yeah we said okay
um how does the brain make a prediction
like i i'm about to grab this water
bottle
and my brain is predicting what i'm
going to feel um on all my parts of my
fingers if i felt something really odd
on any part here i notice it
so my brain is predicting what it's
going to feel as i grab this thing
so what is that how does that manifest
itself in neural tissue right we got
brains made of neurons and there's
chemicals and there's neurons and
there's spikes and the connect you know
where where is the prediction going on
and one argument could be that well when
i'm predicting something
um a neuron must be firing in advance
it's like okay this neuron represents
what you're going to feel and it's
firing it's sending a spike
and certainly that happens to some
extent but our predictions are so
ubiquitous
that we're making so many of them which
we're totally unaware of just the vast
majority we have no idea that you're
doing this
um that it wasn't really
we were trying to figure how could this
be where where is these where are these
happening
right and i won't walk you through the
whole story unless you
insist upon it but we came to the
realization
that most of your predictions are
occurring
inside individual neurons especially
these the most common are in the
pyramidal cells
and there are there's a property of
neurons
we everyone knows or most people know
that a neuron is a cell and it has this
spike
called an action potential and it sends
information
but we now know that there's these
spikes internal to the neuron
they're called dendritic spikes they
travel along the branches of the neuron
and they don't leave the neuron they're
just internal only
there's far more dendritic spikes than
there are action potentials
far more they're happening all the time
and
what we came to understand that those
dendritic spikes the ones that are
occurring are actually a form of
prediction
they're telling the neuron the neuron is
saying i expect
that i might become active shortly and
that internal
so the internal spike is a way of saying
you're going to you might be generating
external spikes soon
i predicted you're going to become
active and and we we've we've
we wrote a paper in 2016 which explained
and how this
manifests itself in neural tissue and
how it is that this all works together
but the vast ma we think it's there's a
lot of evidence supporting it
um so we that's where we think that most
of these predictions are internal that's
why you can't
be per their internal neuron you can't
perceive them
from understanding the the prediction
mechanism of a single neuron
do you think there's deep insights to be
gained about the prediction
capabilities of the mini brains within
the bigger brain and the brain oh yeah
yeah yeah
so having a prediction side of the
individual neuron is not that useful
you know what so what um the way it
manifests itself
in neural tissue is that
when a neuron a neuron emits these
spikes or a very singular type event
if a neuron is predicting that it's
going to be active it makes it spike
very a little bit sooner just a few
milliseconds sooner than it would have
otherwise it's like
i give the analogy in the book there's
like a sprinter on a on a starting
blocks in
a race and if someone says get ready set
you get up and you're ready to go
and then when your race starts you get a
little bit earlier start so that it's
that
that ready set is like the prediction
and the neuron's like ready to go
quicker
and what happens is when you have a
whole bunch of neurons together
and they're all getting these inputs the
ones that are in the predictive state
the ones that are
anticipating to become active if they do
become active they they happen sooner
they disable everything else and it
leads to different representations in
the brain so
you have to it's not isolated just to
the neuron the prediction occurs within
the neuron
but the network behavior changes so what
happens under different predictions
different inputs have different
representations so how i
what i predict um it's going to be
different under different contexts
you know what my input will be is
different under different context so
this is this is a
key level theory how this works so the
theory of the thousand brains
if you were to count the number of
brains how would you do it
the thousand main theory says that
basically every cortical column
in the in your neurocortex is a complete
modeling system
and that when i ask where do i have a
model of something like a coffee cup
it's not in one of those models it's in
thousands of those models there's
thousands of models of coffee cups
that's what the thousand brains there's
a voting mechanism then there's a voting
mechanism which leads which
is the thing you're which you're
conscious of which leads to your
singular perception
um that's why you perceive something so
that's the thousand brains theory
the details how we got to that theory
um are complicated it wasn't you just
thought of it one day
and one of those details is we had to
ask how does a a model make predictions
and we've talked about just these
predictive neurons
that's part of this theory it's like
saying oh it's a detail but
it was like a crack in the doors like
how are we going to figure out how these
neurons build do this
you know what is going on here so we
just looked at prediction as like
well we know that's ubiquitous we know
that every part of the cortex is making
predictions
therefore whatever the predictive system
is it's going to be everywhere
we know there's a gazillion predictions
happening at once so let's see if we can
start teasing apart
you know ask questions about you know
how could neurons be making these
predictions and that
sort of built up to now what we have the
thousand brains theory
which is complex you know it's just some
i can state it simply but we just didn't
think of it
we had to get there step by step very it
took years
uh to get there and where does uh
reference frames fit in so yeah
okay so again a reference frame i
mentioned
um earlier about the you know a model of
a house and i said if you're going to
build a model of a house
in a computer they have a reference
frame and you can then reference them
like
cartesian coordinates like x y and z
axes
so i can say oh i'm going to design a
house i can say well the
the front door is at this location xyz
and the roof is at this location xyz and
so on
that's a type of reference frame so it
turns out
for you to make a prediction and then i
walk you through the thought experiment
in the book where i was
predicting what my finger was going to
feel when i touched the coffee cup
it was a ceramic coffee cup but this one
will do um
and what i realized is that to make a
prediction with my finger's going to
feel like it's just going to feel
different than this which would feel
different if i touch the hole or the
thing on the bottom
make that prediction the cortex needs to
know where the finger is the tip of the
finger
relative to the coffee cup and exactly
relative to the coffee cup
and to do that i have to have a
reference frame for the coffee up it has
to have a way of representing the
location of my finger
to the coffin up and then we realize of
course every part of your skin has to
have a reference frame relative things
to touch and then we
did the same thing with vision but so
the idea that a reference frame
is necessary to make a prediction when
you're touching something or when you're
seeing something
and you're moving your eyes you're
moving your fingers it's just a
requirement
to know what to predict if i have a if i
have a structure i'm going to make a
prediction i have to
i have to know where it is i'm looking
or touching it
so then we say well how do neurons make
reference frames it's not obvious
you know xyz coordinates don't exist in
the brain it's just not the way it works
so that's when we looked at the older
part of the brain the hippocampus and
the antorano cortex
where we knew that in that part of the
brain
there's a reference frame for a room or
reference name for environment remember
i talked earlier about how you could
know make a map of this room
so we said oh um that they are
implementing reference frames there so
we knew that reference frames needed to
exist in every cortical column
and so that was a deductive thing we
just deduced it
has to go so you take the old
mammalian ability to know where you are
in a particular space
and you start applying that to higher
and higher levels yeah you first you
apply it to physical like where your
finger is
so here's what i think about it the old
part of the brain says where's my body
in this room
yeah the new part of the brain says
where's my finger
relative to this this object yeah where
is
the a section of my retina relative to
this object like where where is
i'm looking at one little corner where
is that relative to this patch of my
retina yeah
um and then we take the same thing and
apply it to concepts
mathematics physics you know humanity
whatever you want to think eventually
you're pondering your own mortality
well whatever but the point is when we
think about the world when we have
knowledge about the world how is that
knowledge organized
lex where do you where is it in your
head the answer is it's in reference
frames
so the way i learn the structure of this
water bottle
where the features are relative to each
other when i think about history or
democracy or mathematics
the same basic underlying structures
happening there's reference frames for
where the knowledge
that you're assigning things to so in
the book i go through examples like
mathematics
and language and politics but
the evidence is very clear in the
neuroscience the same mechanism that we
use to model this coffee cup we're going
to use to model
high level thoughts your your your
demise of the humanity whatever you want
to think about
it's interesting to think about how
different are the representations of
those
higher dimensional concepts
higher level concepts how different the
representation there is in terms of
reference frames
versus spatial but interesting thing
it's it's
it's a different application but it's
the exact same mechanism
but isn't there some aspect to uh
higher level concepts that they seem to
be hierarchical
like they just seem to integrate a lot
of information into so
is our physical objects so take this
water bottle
uh i'm not particular to this brand but
this is a fiji water bottle
and it has um a logo and i use this
example in my book
our company's coffee cup has a logo on
it but
this object is hierarchical it is
it's got like a cylinder and a cap but
then has this logo on it and the logo
has a word the word has letters the
letters of different features
and so i don't have to remember i don't
think about this so i said oh there's a
fiji logo on this water bottle i don't
have to go through and say
oh what is the fiji logo it's the f and
i and the j and i and there's a hibiscus
flower and
and uh oh it has the pest you know the
stamen on it i don't have to do that i
just incorporate all of that
in some sort of hierarchical
representation i say um
you know put this logo on this water
bottle yeah and
and and then the logo has a word and the
word has letters
all hierarchical just all that stuff is
big it's amazing that the brain
instantly just does all that yeah the
idea that there's there's water it's
liquid and the idea that you can
uh drink it when you're thirsty the idea
that there's brands
yeah and then there's like all of that
information is
instantly like built into the whole
thing
once you proceed so i wanted to get back
to your point about hierarchical
representation
the world itself is hierarchical right
and i can take this microphone in front
of me i know inside there's going to be
some electronics i know there's going to
be some wires and i know there's going
to be a little
diaphragm that moves back and forth i
don't see that but i know it
so everything in the world is
hierarchical you just go into room it's
composed of other components the kitchen
has a refrigerator you know
the refrigerator has a door the door has
a hinge the hinge has screws and pin
yeah i mean
so anyway the the the modeling system
that exists in every cortical column
learns the hierarchical structure of
objects
so it's a very sophisticated modeling
system in this grain of rice it's hard
to imagine but this grain of ice can do
really sophisticated things it's got a
hundred thousand neurons in it
it's very sophisticated so that same
mechanism that can model a water bottle
or a coffee cup can model conceptual
objects as well
it's if that's the beauty of this
discovery that this guy vernon mount
castle made many many years ago which is
that
there's there's a single cortical
algorithm underlying everything we're
doing
so so common sense concepts and higher
level concepts are all
represented in the same way they're set
in the same mechanisms yeah
it's a little bit like computers right
all computers are universal turing
machines
even the little teeny one that's in my
toaster
and the big one that's you know running
some cloud server or someplace
um they're all running on the same
principle they can apply different
things
so the brain is all built on the same
principle it's all about
learning these models structured models
using movement
and reference frames and it can be
applied to
something as simple as a water bottle in
a coffee cup and it can be just thinking
like what's the future of humanity and
you know why do you have a hedgehog on
your
on your desk i don't know nobody knows
i think it's hedgehog that's right it's
a hedgehog in the fog
it's a russian reference does it give
you any
inclination or hope about how difficult
it is to engineer
common sense reasoning so how
complicated this
is this whole process so looking at the
brain
is this a marvel of engineering or is it
pretty dumb stuff stacked on top of each
other over and over
can it be both can it be both right
i don't know if it can be both because
uh
if it's an incredible engineering job
that means it's
v so evolution did a lot of work it
uh yeah but then but then it just copied
that
right so as i said earlier the figuring
out how to model something
like a space is really hard and
evolution had to go through a lot of
trick and these these these cells i was
talking about these grid cells and place
cells they're really complicated this is
not simple stuff
this neural tissue works on these really
unexpected weird mechanisms um
but it did it it figured it out but but
now you can just make lots of copies of
it
but then finding yeah so it's a very
interesting idea that's a lot of copies
of a basic mini brain
but the question is how difficult it is
to find that mini brain that you can
copy and paste
uh effectively okay today we
know enough to build this i'm sitting
here with
you know i know the steps we have to go
there's still some engineering problems
to solve
but we know enough and this is not like
oh this is an interesting idea
we have to go think about it for another
few decades no we actually understand in
pretty well details
so not all the details but most of them
so it's complicated but it is an
engineering problem
so in my company we are working on that
we are basically
a road map how we do this um it's not
going to take decades
it's better a few years um
[Music]
optimistically but i think that's
possible um
it's you know complex things if you
understand them you can build them
so in which domain do you think it's
best to
build them are we talking about robotics
like
uh entities that operate in the physical
world that are able to interact with
that world are we talking about entities
that operate in the digital world
are we talking about something more like
uh
more specific like is done in the uh
machine learning community where you
look at natural language
or computer vision where do you think is
easiest it's the first it's the first
two more than the third one i would say
um again again let's just use computers
as an analogy
um the pioneers of computing people like
john van noyman and
um turing they created this thing you
know we now call the universal turing
machine which is the computer right
did they know how it was going to be
applied where it was going to be used
you know could they
envision any of the future no they just
said this is like a really interesting
computational idea about algorithms
and how you can implement them in in a
machine
and we're doing something similar to
that today like we are
we are building this sort of universal
learning principle
that can be applied to many many
different things
but the the robotics piece of that okay
the interactive okay all right let's
be specific you can think of this
cortical column as this what we call a
sensory motor learning system it has the
idea that there's a sensor
and then it's moving that sensor can be
physical it could be like my finger
and it's moving in the world it could
like my eye and it's physically moving
it can also be virtual so it could be
um an example would be i could have a
system that lives in the internet
that that actually samples information
on the internet and moves by following
links
that's that's a sensory motor system so
something that echoes the the process of
a finger moving along a
car but in a very very loose sense it's
it's like
again learning is inherently about the
subbing the structure in the world and
discover the structure of the world you
have to move through the world
even if it's a virtual world even if
it's a conceptual world
you have to move through it you don't it
doesn't exist in one
it has some structure to it so
here's here's a couple of predictions
that getting what you're talking about
in humans the same algorithm is does
robotics right it moves my arms my eyes
my body
right um and so
in my in the future to me robotics and
ai will merge
they're not going to be separate fields
because they're going to the the
the algorithms to really controlling
robots are going to be the same
algorithms we have in our brand the
brain at these sensory motor algorithms
i today we're not there but i think
that's going to happen
and and then so but not all ai systems
will have b robotics
you can have systems that have very
different types of embodiments some will
have physical movements
some will have non-physical movements
it's a very generic
learning system again it's like
computers the turing machine is it's
like
it doesn't say how it's supposed to be
implemented it doesn't tell how big it
is doesn't tell you what you apply it to
but it's an interesting it's a
computational principle
cortical column equivalent is a
computational principle is about
learning
it's about how you learn and it can be
applied to a gazillion things this is
what i think this is
i think this impact of ai is going to be
as large if not larger than computing
has been in the last century by far
because it's it's getting at a
fundamental thing it's not a vision
system or a learning system it's a
it's not a vision system or a hearing
system it is a learning system it's a
fundamental principle how you learn the
structure in the world
how you can gain knowledge and be
intelligent and that's what the thousand
brain says what's going on and we have a
particular implementation in our head
but doesn't have to be like that at all
do you think there's going to be some
kind of impact
okay let me ask it another way what do
uh increasingly intelligent ai systems
do with us humans in the following way
like how hard is the human in the loop
problem
how hard is it to to interact
the finger on the coffee cup equivalent
of having a conversation with a human
being
so how hard is it to fit into our little
human world
uh i don't i think it's a lot of
engineering problems i don't think it's
a fundamental problem i could ask you
the same question how hard is for
computers to fit into a human world
right that i mean that's essentially
what i'm asking like how
um much are we uh elitist are we as
humans
like we try to keep out uh systems
i don't know i i sure i think i'm not
sure that's the right question
let's let's look at computers as an
analogy computers are million times
faster than us they do things we can't
understand most people have no idea
what's going on when they use computers
right how do we integrate them in our
society
um well they're that we don't think of
them as their own entities
they're not living things um we don't
afford them rights
um we uh we rely on them
our survival as a seven billion people
or something like that
is relying on computers now um don't you
think that's a fundamental problem
that we see them as something we can't
we don't give rights to
so computers so yeah computers so uh
robots computers intelligence systems it
feels like for them to operate
successfully
they would need to have a lot of the
elements
that we would start having to think
about like
should this entity have rights i i don't
think so i
i think it's tempting to think that way
personally i don't think anyone hardly
anyone thinks that for computers today
no one says oh this thing
needs a right i shouldn't be able to
turn it off or you know if i throw it in
the trash can
you know and hit it with a sledgehammer
i might perform a criminal act no no one
thinks that
um and now we think about intelligent
machines
which is where you're going um
and and all of a sudden like well now we
can't do that
i think the basic problem we have here
is that people think intelligent
machines will be like us
they're going to have the same emotions
as we do the same feelings as we do
what if i can build an intelligent
machine that have absolutely could care
less about whether it was on or off or
destroyed or not
it just doesn't care it's just like a
map it's just a modeling system
it has no desires to live nothing
is it possible to create a system that
can model the world deeply and not care
about whether it lives or dies
absolutely no question about it
to me that's not 100 percent obvious
it's obvious to me so okay
we can debate it if you want yeah where
does your where does your desire to live
come from
it's an old evolutionary design
i mean we could argue does it really
matter if we live or not objectively no
right we're all going to die eventually
um
but evolution makes us want to live
evolution makes us want to fight to live
evolutionists want to care and love one
another and to care for our children
and our relatives and our family and and
so on
and those are all good things but they
come about not because we're smart
because we're animals that grew up you
know the the hummingbird in my backyard
cares about its offspring
you know the every living thing in some
sense cares about you know
surviving but when we talk about
creating intelligent machines we're not
creating
life we're not creating evolving
creatures we're not creating
living things we're just creating a
machine that can learn
really sophisticated stuff and that
machine it may even be able to talk to
us
but it doesn't it's not going to have a
desire to live
unless somehow we put it into that
system well
there's learning right the the thing is
but you don't learn to like want to live
that's built into you it's wow people
like ernest becker argue
so okay uh there's the fact the
finiteness of life
the way we think about it is something
we learn
uh perhaps so okay yeah and some people
decide they don't want to live
and some people decide you know you can
but the desire to live is built in dna
right
but i think what i'm trying to get to is
uh in order to accomplish goals
it's useful to have the urgency of
mortality is what the stoics talked
about
is meditating in your mortality yeah it
might be a very useful
thing to do to die and have the urgency
of death
and to realize that to uh conceive
yourself as an entity
that operates in this world that
eventually will no longer be a part of
this world and actually conceive of
yourself as a conscious entity might be
very useful
for you to be a system that makes sense
of the world
otherwise you might get lazy well okay
we're going to build these machines
right and so we're talking about
building
ais what but we're we're building the uh
uh the the the equivalent of the
cortical columns the uh the neocortex
the neocortex and the the question is
where do they
arrive at because we're not hard-coding
everything in
where uh well well in terms of if you
build the neocortex equivalent
it will not have any of these desires or
emotional states now you can
argue that that neocortex won't be
useful
unless i give it some agency unless i
give it some desire unless i give it
some motivation otherwise you'll be as
lazy and do nothing
right you could argue that um but on its
own
it's not going to do those things it's
just not it's not going to sit there and
say
i understand the world therefore i care
to live no it's not going to do that
it's just going to say i understand the
world
why is that obvious to you why why why
don't do you think it's
okay let me ask it this way do you think
it's possible
it will at least assign to itself
agency and perceive
itself in this world as being a
conscious entity
as a useful way to operate in the world
and and to make sense of the world
i think intelligent machine could be
conscious but that doesn't not
again imply any of these um these
desires and goals and
and that you're worried about it we can
i have a
we can talk about what it means for the
machine to be conscious and by the way
not worry about but get excited about
it's not necessarily that we should
worry about it so i think there's a
legitimate
problem or not problem a question asked
if you build this modeling system what's
it gonna model
yes right what's it what's its desire
what is it what's its goal what are we
applying it to
right so that's an interesting question
um
one thing if it and it depends on the
application
it's not something that inherent to the
modeling system it's something we apply
to the modeling system in a particular
way
so if i wanted to make a really smart
car it would have to know
about driving in cars and what's
important in driving in cars
it's not going to figure that out on its
own it's not going to sit there and say
you know i've understood the world
and i've decided you know no no no we
have to tell it we're going to have to
say like
so i imagine i make this car really
smart it learns about your driving
habits it learns about the world
and it's just you know is it one day
going to wake up and say
you know what i'm tired of driving and
doing what you want
i think i have better ideas about how to
spend my time well
okay no it's not going to do that part
of me is playing a little bit of devil's
advocate but part of me
is also trying to think through this
because
i've studied cars quite a bit and i
studied pedestrians and cyclists quite a
bit
and there's part of me that thinks
that there needs to be
more intelligence than we realize in
order to drive successfully
that game theory of human interaction
seems to require some deep understanding
of
of human nature that
okay when a pedestrian crosses the
street there's some sense
they they look at a car usually and then
they look away
there's some sense in which they say i
believe that you're not going to murder
me
you don't have the guts to murder me
this is the little dance of pedestrian
car interaction
yeah is saying i'm going to look away
and i'm going to put my
life in your hands because i think
you're human you're not gonna kill me
and then the car in order to
successfully operate in
like manhattan streets has to say no no
no
i am going to kill you like a little bit
there's a little bit of this weird
inkling of
mutual murder yeah yeah and that's a
dance and then somehow
successfully operate through do you
think you were born of that did you
learn that social interaction
uh i think it might have a lot of the
same elements that you're talking about
which is we're leveraging
things we were born with and applying
them in the context
that uh all right i would i would answer
that i would have said that that kind of
interaction
is learned because you know people in
different cultures have different
interactions like that
if you cross the street in different
cities and different around the world
they have different ways of interacting
i would say that's learned and i would
say an intelligent system could learn
that too
but that does not lead and the
intelligent system can understand
humans it could understand that you know
just like i can study an animal and
learn something about that animal
you know i could study apes and learn
something about their culture and so on
i'd have to be an ape to know that um i
may not be
completely but i can understand
something so intel's machine can model
that that's this part of the world is
this part of the interactions
the question we're trying to get at will
the intelligent machine
have its own personal agency that's
beyond you know what we assign to it or
it's its own personal
you know goals or will it evolve and
create these things
my confidence comes from understanding
the mechanisms
i'm talking about creating this is not
hand wave stuff
it's down in the details we i'm going to
build it and i know what it's going to
look like and i know it's
going to behave i know what the kind of
things it could do and the kind of
things it can't do
just like when i build a computer i know
it's not going to on its own decide to
put another
register inside of it it can't do that
no way
no matter what your software does it
can't add a register to the computer
um so in this way when we build ai
systems
we have to make choices about the the
the under the how we embed them so i
talked about this in the book i said you
know
it's a brain intelligence system is not
just the neocortex equivalent
you have to have that but it has to have
some kind of embodiment physical a
virtual
it has to have some sort of goals it has
to have some sort of uh ideas about
dangers about things it shouldn't do
like you know like we
we build in safeguards into systems uh
we have them in our bodies we have put
them into cars
right you know my car follows my
directions until the day it sees
i'm about to hit something and it
ignores my directions and puts the
brakes on
so we can build those things in so
that's a very interesting problem
um how to build those in i think my
my my differing opinion about the risks
of ai for most people
is that people assume that somehow those
things will just appear automatically
it'll evolve and intelligence itself
begets that stuff or requires it but
it's not intelligence
of the neural cortex equipment doesn't
require this the new cartridge equipment
just says
i'm a learning system tell me what you
want me to learn and i'll tell you
ask me questions i'll tell you the
answers but
in that again it's again like a map it
doesn't a map has no
intent about things but you can use it
um
to solve problems okay so the building
engineering the neural cortex in itself
is just creating
an intelligent prediction system
modeling system
sorry modeling system yeah uh you can
use it to then make predictions and then
but you can also put it inside a thing
that's actually acting in this world
you have to put it inside something it's
again think of the map analogy right map
on its own doesn't do anything right
it's just inert it's just it can learn
but it's just so we have to embed it
somehow in something to do something
so so what's your intuition here you had
a conversation
with sam harris recently that was uh
sort of um
you've had a bit of a disagreement and
you're sticking on this point
you know elon musk stuart russell
kind of have us worry existential
threats of ai what's your intuition why
if we engineer an increasingly
intelligent neural cortex type of system
in the computer why that shouldn't be a
thing that we
it was interesting we used the word
intuition and sam harris used the word
intuition too
and and when he used that intuition that
word i immediately stopped and said oh
that's the
problem he's using intuition i'm not
speaking about my intuition
yes i'm speaking about something i
understand something i'm going to build
something i am building
something i understand completely or at
least well enough to know what it's all
i'm guessing i know what this thing's
going to do and
i think most people who are worried they
have trouble
separating out they don't have they
don't have the um knowledge or the
understanding
about like what is intelligence how is
it manifest in the brain how is it
separate from these other functions in
the brain
and so they imagine it's going to be
human-like or animal-like it's going to
have it's going to have the same sort of
drives and emotions we have but there's
no reason for that
that's just because there's there's
unknown if you're if the unknown is like
oh my god you know i don't know what
this is going to do we have to be
careful it could be like us but really
smarter
i'm saying no it won't be like us it'll
be really smart but it won't be like us
at all
and um and but i i'm coming from that
not because i just
guessing i'm not intuitive using
intuition i'm basically like okay i
understand this thing works this is what
it does
let me explain it to you okay but uh to
push back
so i also disagree with the the
intuitions that sam has
but but i also disagree with what you
just said
which you know what's a good uh analogy
so if you look at the
twitter algorithm in in the early days
just recommender systems you can
understand how recommender systems work
what you can't understand in the early
days is when you apply that recommender
system at scale
to thousands and millions of people how
that can change societies
yeah so the question is yes
you're just saying this is how an
engineer in neurocortex
works but the ques like when you have a
very useful
uh tic toc type of service that goes
viral when your neural cortex
goes viral and then millions of people
start using it cannot destroy the world
no
uh well first of all this is back one
thing i want to say is that uh
ai is a dangerous technology i don't i'm
not denying that all technology is
dangerous well an ai
maybe particularly so yeah okay so um
am i worried about it yeah i'm totally
worried about it the the thing where
the narrow component we're talking about
now is the existential risk of ai
right so i want to make that distinction
because i think ai can be applied poorly
it can be applied in ways that you know
people are going to
understand the consequences of it
these are all potentially very bad
things
but they're not the ai system creating
this existential risk on its own
and that's the only place i disagree
with other people right so
so i i think the existential risk thing
is um
humans are really damn good at surviving
so to kill off the human race
it'd be very very difficult you can even
yes but you can even i'll go further i
don't think ai systems are ever going to
try to i don't think ar systems are ever
going to like say
i'm going to ignore you i'm going to do
what i think is best
i don't think that's going to happen at
least not in the way
i'm talking about it so you the twitter
recommendation algorithm this
interesting example
let's let's use computer as an analogy
again right
i build a computer it's a universal
computing machine i can't predict what
people are going to use it for they can
build all kinds of things they can
they can even create computer viruses
it's you know all kinds of stuff
so there's some unknown about its
utility about where it's going to go
but on the other hand i pointed out that
once i build a computer
it's not going to fundamentally change
how it computes
it's like i use the example of a
register which is a part internal part
of a computer
um you know i say it can't just say
because computers don't evolve
they don't replicate they don't evolve
they don't you know the physical
manifestation of the computer itself
is not gonna there's certain things it
can't do right so we can
break into things like things that are
possible to happen we can't predict
and things are just impossible to happen
unless we go out of our way to make them
happen they're not going to happen
unless somebody makes them happen yeah
so there's there's a bunch of things to
say one
is the physical aspect which you're
absolutely right
we have to build a thing for it to
operate in the physical world
and you can just stop building them uh
you know the moment they're not doing
the thing you want them to do or just
change the design
or change the design the question is i
mean there's it's possible in the
physical world
this is probably longer term is you
automate the building
it makes it makes a lot of sense to
automate the building there's a lot of
factories that are doing more and more
and more
automation to go from raw resources to
the final product
it's possible to imagine that it's
obviously much more efficient to keep
to create a factory that's creating
robots that do something you know do
something extremely useful for society
it could be uh
personal assistance it could be uh it
could be it could be your toaster but a
toaster that's much
has deeper knowledge of your culinary
preferences yeah
and and that could uh well i think now
you've hit on the right thing the real
thing we need to be worried about lex
is self-replication right that is the
thing that we're in the physical world
yeah or even the virtual world
self-replication
because self-replication is dangerous
it's probably more likely to be killed
by a virus you know or a human
engineered virus
anybody can create you know this the
technology is getting so almost anybody
but not anybody but
a lot of people could create a
human-engineered virus that could wipe
out humanity
that is really dangerous no intelligence
required just self-replication
so um so we need to be careful about
that
so when i think about you know ai
i'm not thinking about robots building
robots don't do that don't build a
you know just well that's because you're
interested in creating intelligence
it seems like self-replication
is a good way to make a lot of money
well fine but
so is you know maybe editing viruses is
a good way to i don't know
the point is if as a society when we
want to look at existential risks
the existential risks we face that that
we can control
almost all evolve around
self-replication yes
the question is i don't see a good uh
way to make a lot of money by
engineering viruses and deploying them
in the world
there could be there will be
applications that are useful but let's
separate out let's
separate out i mean you don't need to
you only need some you know terrorists
who wants to do it because it doesn't
take a lot of money to make viruses
um let's just separate out what's risky
and what's not risky
i'm arguing that the intelligence side
of this equation is not risky it's not
risky it's not risky at all
it's the self-replication side of the
equation is risky and
i'm not dismissing that i'm scared as
hell it's like the paperclip
maximizer thing yeah those are often
like
talked about in the same conversation um
i think you're right like creating
ultra-intelligent super-intelligent
systems is not necessarily coupled with
the self-replicating arbitrarily
self-replicating systems
yeah and you don't get evolution unless
you're self-replicating yeah
and so i think that's the gist of this
argument that people have trouble
separating those two out they just think
oh yeah intelligence is like us
and look how look at the damage we've
done to this planet like how we've
you know destroyed all these other
species yeah well we replicate we're
eight billion of us are seven million of
us now so um
i think the idea is that the the more
intelligent
we're able to build systems the more
tempting
it becomes from a capitalist perspective
of creating products the more tempting
it becomes to create
self uh reproduction systems all right
so let's say that's true so does that
mean we don't build intelligent systems
no that means we regulate
we we understand the risks uh we
regulate them
yeah uh you know look there's a lot of
things we could do a society which have
some sort of financial benefit to
someone
which could do a lot of harm and we have
to learn how to regulate those things
we have to learn how to deal with those
things i will argue this i would say the
opposite
i would say having intelligent machines
at our disposal
will actually help us in the end more
because it'll help us understand these
risks better and help us mitigate these
risk riders there might be ways of
saying oh
well how do we solve climate change
problems you know how do we do this or
how do we do that
that just like computers are dangerous
in the hands of the wrong people but
they've been so great for so many other
things we live with those dangers
and i think we have to do the same with
intelligent machines we just but we have
to be constantly vigilant about
this idea of a bad actors doing bad
things with them and b
um don't ever ever create a
self-replicating system
um and by the way i don't even know if
you could create a self-replicating
system
that uses a factory that's really
dangerous you know
nature's way of self-replicating is so
amazing
um you know it doesn't require anything
it just me know
the thing and resources and it goes
right yeah
if i said to you you know what we have
to build uh
our goal is to build a factory that can
make that builds new factories
and it has to end to end supply chain
it has to mine the resources get the
energy
i mean that's really hard it's you know
no one's doing that in the next
you know 100 years i've been extremely
impressed
by the efforts of elon musk and tesla to
try to do exactly that
not not from raw resource well he
actually i think
states the goal is to go from raw
resource to the
uh the final car in one factory yeah
that's that's the main goal of course
it's not currently possible
but they're taking huge leaps well he's
not the only one to do that
this has been a goal for many uh
industries for a long long time
um it's difficult to do well a lot of
people what they do is instead they have
like
a million suppliers and then they like
there's
everybody's men they all co-locate them
and
they tie the systems together it's it's
a fundamentally distributed even
i think that's that also is not getting
at the issue i was just talking about um
which is self-replication it's
um i mean self-replication means there's
no entity involved other than the entity
that's replicating
um right and so if there's humans in
this in the loop
that's not really self-replicating right
it's unless
somehow we're duped but
it's also i i don't necessarily
agree with you because you've kind of
mentioned that ai will not say no to us
i i just think they will yeah yeah so
like
uh i think it's a useful feature to
build in i'm just trying to like
uh put myself in the mind of engineers
to sometimes say no
you know if you you yeah well i gave an
example earlier right i get an example
of my car
yeah right my car turns the wheel and
and
applies the accelerator and the brake as
i say until
it decides there's something dangerous
yes and then it doesn't do that
yeah now that was something
it didn't decide to do is something we
programmed into the car
uh and so good it was a good idea right
the question again isn't like if we
create an intelligent system will it
ever
ignore our commands of course it will on
sometimes is it going to do it because
it came
up came up with its own goals that serve
its purposes
and it doesn't care about our purposes
no i don't think that's going to happen
okay so let me ask you about these uh
super intelligent cortical systems that
we engineer
and us humans
do you think uh with these entities
operating out there in the world
what does the future most promising
future look like is it
us merging with them
or is it us like how do we keep
us humans around when you have
increasingly intelligent beings is it
uh one of the dreams is to upload our
minds in the digital space
so can we just give our minds
to these uh systems yeah so they can
operate on them
is there some kind of more interesting
merger or is there more more
in the third part of my book i talked
about all these scenarios and let me
just walk through them
sure um the uploading the mind one yes
extremely really difficult to do like
like we have no idea how to do this even
remotely right now um so it would be a
very long way away
but i make the argument you wouldn't
like the result
um and you wouldn't be pleased with the
result it's really not what you think
it's going to be
um imagine i could upload your brain
into into a computer right now and now
the computer's sitting there going hey
i'm over here
great get rid of that old bio person i
don't need them you're still sitting
here
yeah what are you gonna do no no that's
not me i'm here right yeah are you gonna
feel satisfied
that then you but people imagine look
i'm on my deathbed and
i'm about to you know expire and i push
the button and now i'm uploaded but
think about it a little differently and
and so i don't think it's going to be a
thing because people
by the time we're able to do this if
ever
because you have to replicate the entire
body not just the brain it's
it's really it's i walk through the
issues it's really substantial
um do you have a sense of what makes us
us
is there is there a shortcut to what can
only save a certain part
that makes us truly ours no but i think
that machine would feel like it's you
too
right right if you people just like i
have a child i have a child right i have
two daughters
they're independent people i created
them well partly yeah
and um uh i don't
just because they're somewhat like me i
don't feel i'm them and they don't feel
like i'm me so if you split it apart you
have two people so
we can come back to what what makes what
consciousness we want we can talk about
that
but we don't have a remote consciousness
i'm not sitting there going oh i'm
conscious of that you know i mean that
system over there so let's say let's
let's stay on our topic okay so
one was uploading a brand yep ain't
gonna happen in a hundred years
maybe a thousand but i don't think
people are gonna wanna do it
the merging your mind with uh
you know the neural link thing right
like again
really really difficult it's it's one
thing to make progress to control a
prosthetic arm it's another to have like
a billion
or several billion you know things and
understanding what those signals mean
like it's the one thing they're like
okay i can learn to think some patterns
to make something happen
it's quite another thing to have a
system a computer which actually knows
exactly which cells it's talking to and
how it's talking to them and interacting
in a way like that
very very difficult we're not getting
anywhere closer to that
um interesting can i uh can i ask a
question here
what so for me what makes that merger
very difficult
practically in the next 10 20 50 years
is like literally the biology side of it
which is like
it's just hard to do that kind of
surgery in a safe way
but your intuition is even the machine
learning
part of it where the machine has to
learn what the heck it's talking to
that's even hard
i think it's even harder and it's not
it's it's easy to do when you're talking
about hundreds of signals
it's it's a totally different thing to
say you're talking about billions of
signals
so you don't think it's the raw it's a
machine learning problem you don't think
it could be learned
well i'm just saying no i think you'd
have to have detailed knowledge
you'd have to know exactly what the
types of neurons you're connecting to
i mean in the brain there's these
they're neurons that do all different
types of things it's not like a neural
network it's a very complex organism
system up here we talked about the grid
cells or the place cells you know you
have to know what kind of cells you're
talking to and what they're doing and
how their timing works and all
all this stuff which you can't today
there's no way of doing that right
but i think it's i think it's a i think
the problem you're right that the
biological
aspect of like who wants to have surgery
and have this stuff inserted in your
brain
that's a problem but this is when we
solve that problem
i think the the information coding
aspect is much worse
i think that's much more it's not like
what they're doing today today it's
simple machine learning stuff
because you're doing simple things but
if you want to merge your brain like i'm
thinking
on the internet i'm merge my brain with
the machine and we're both doing
i that's a totally different issue
that's interesting i i tend to think if
okay if you have a super clean signal
from a bunch of neurons at the start you
don't know what those neurons are
i think that's much easier than
the getting of the clean signal i think
if you
think about today's machine learning
that's what you would conclude
right i'm thinking about what's going on
in the brain and i don't reach that
conclusion so we'll have to see
sure but i don't think even even then i
think there's kind of a sad
future like you know do i do i have to
like
plug my brain into a computer i'm still
a biological organism i assume i'm still
going to die
so what what have i achieved right you
know what have i achieved to do some
sort of oh
i i disagree we don't know what those
are but it seems like there could be a
lot of different applications
it's like virtual reality is to expand
your brain's capability to uh
to to like to read wikipedia yeah but
but fine but but you're still a
biological organization yes yes you know
you're still
you're still mortal you're still all
right so what are you accomplishing
you're making your life in this
short period of time better right just
like uh
having the internet made our life better
yeah yeah okay so i
i think that's of of if i think about
all the possible gains we can have here
that's a marginal one
it's an individual hey i'm better you
know i'm smarter
um but you know fine i'm not against it
i just don't think it's earth-changing
i but so this is the true of the
internet
when each of us individuals are smarter
we get a chance to then share our
smartness
we get smarter and smarter together as
like as a collective this is kind of
like this ant colony
but why don't i just create an
intelligent machine that doesn't have
any of this biological nonsense
this is all the same it's it's
everything except
don't burden it with my brain yeah right
it
has a brain it is smart it's like my
child but it's much much smarter than me
so i have a choice between doing some
implant doing some hybrid weird you know
biological thing that bleeding and all
these problems
and limited by my brain or creating a
system which is super smart that i can
talk to
um that helps me understand the world
they can read the inter you know read
wikipedia and talk to me
i i guess my uh the open questions there
are
what does the manifestation of super
intelligence look like so
like what are we going to you talked
about why do i want to merge with ai
like what
what's the actual marginal benefit here
if i
if we have a super intelligent system
yeah how will it make our life better
so let's let's that's a great question
but let's break it down to little pieces
all right
on the one hand it can make our life
better in lots of simple ways
you mentioned like a care robot or
something that helps me do things it
cooks i don't know what it does right
little things like that we have soup
better smarter cars we can have
you know better agents and aids helping
us in our work environment and things
like that to me that's like the easy
stuff the
simple stuff in the beginning um
and so in the same way that computers
made our lives better in
ways many many ways i will have those
kind of things
to me the really exciting thing about ai
is
sort of its transcendent transcendent
quality in terms of humanity
we're still biological organisms we're
still stuck here on earth
it's going to be hard for us to live
anywhere else i don't think
you and i are going to want to live on
mars anytime soon
and um and we're flawed
you know we may end up destroying
ourselves it's
totally possible uh we if not completely
we could destroy our civilizations
you know it's let's face the fact we
have issues here
but we can create intelligent machines
that can help us in various ways for
example one example i gave
another sounds a little sci-fi but i
believe this if we really wanted to live
on mars
we'd have to have intelligent systems
that go there and build the habitat for
us
not humans humans are never going to do
this it's just too hard
um but could we have a thousand or ten
thousand you know
engineer workers up there doing this
stuff building things terraforming mars
sure
maybe we can move to mars but then if we
want to if we want to go around the
universe
should i send my children around the
universe or should i send some
intelligent machine which is like a
child
that represents me and understands our
needs here on earth
that could travel through space so it's
sort of
it in some sense intelligence allows us
to transcend our
the limitations of our biology uh
with and and don't think of it as a
negative thing it's in some sense
my children transcend my the my biology
too
because they they live beyond me yeah um
and we impart
they represent me and they also have
their own knowledge and i can impart
knowledge to them so intelligent
machines will be like that too
but not limited like us but the question
is um
there's so many ways that transcendence
can happen
and the merger with ai and humans is one
of those ways so
you said intelligent basically beings or
systems
propagating throughout the universe
representing us humans
they represent us humans in the sense
they represent our knowledge and our
history
not us individually right
right but i mean the question is is it
just the database
with uh with the really damn good uh
model
no they're conscious conscious just like
us okay
but just different they're different
just like my children are different
they're like me but they're different um
these are more different
i guess maybe i've already i kind of
i take a very broad view of our life
here on
on earth i say you know why are we
living here are we just living because
we live
is are we surviving because we can
survive are we fighting just because
we want to just keep going what's the
point of it yeah right
so to me the point if i ask myself
what's the point of life is
what transcends that ephemeral sort of
biological experience
is to me this is my answer is
the acquisition of knowledge to
understand more about the universe
and to explore and that's partly to
learn more
right i don't view it as
a terrible thing if the ultimate
outcome of humanity is we create systems
that are intelligent
that are our offspring but are not like
us at all and we stay
we stay here and live on earth as long
as we can which won't be forever
but as long as we can and
but that would be a great thing to do
it's not a it's not like a
negative thing well would uh
you'd be okay then if uh the human
species vanishes but our knowledge is
preserved
and keeps being expanded by intelligent
systems
i want our knowledge to be preserved and
expanded
yeah am i okay with humans dying no i
don't want that to happen
but if if if it does happen what if we
we were sitting here and this is uh
we're the last two people on earth we're
saying lex we blew it
it's all over right yeah wouldn't i feel
better if i
knew that our knowledge was preserved
and that we had agents
represent that knew about that that were
trans you know they were that left earth
i would want that it's better than not
having that you know i make the analogy
of like you know the dinosaurs the poor
dinosaurs they live for you know tens of
millions of years
they raised their kids they you know
they they fought to survive they were
hungry they
they they did everything we do and then
they're all gone
yeah like you know and and if we didn't
discover their bones
nobody would ever know that they ever
existed right
do we want to be like that i don't want
to be like that but there's a sad aspect
to it and
it's kind of it's jarring to think about
that
it's possible that a human-like
intelligent civilization has previously
existed on earth
oh yeah the reason i say this is like it
is
jarring to think that we would not if
they weren't extinct we wouldn't be able
to find evidence of them
after a sufficient amount after a
sufficient amount of time
of course there's like look basically
humans like if we destroy ourselves now
human civilization destroy ourselves now
after a sufficient amount of time we
would not be
we'd find the evidence of the dinosaurs
we would not find evidence
of those humans yeah that's kind of an
odd thing to think about although
i'm not sure if we have enough knowledge
about
species going back for billions of years
that we could we could
we might be able to eliminate that
possibility but it's an interesting
question
of course this is a similar question to
you know there were lots of intelligent
species throughout the without our
galaxy
that have all disappeared yeah that's
super sad that
um there exactly that
there may have been much more
intelligent alien civilizations in our
galaxy
that are no longer there yeah um you
actually talked about this
um that humans might destroy ourselves
yeah
and how we might preserve our knowledge
yeah and advertise that knowledge
to other advertisers a funny word to use
from a pr person there's no financial
gain in this
uh you know like make it like from a
tourism perspective make it interesting
can you describe how well there's a
couple things i broke it down to the two
parts
actually three parts one is um
you know there's a lot of things we know
that what if what if we were to what if
we ended
up our civilization collapsed yeah i'm
not talking tomorrow yeah we could be a
thousand years from now alex you know we
don't really know but
but historically would be likely at some
point time flies when you're having fun
yeah that's a good way to put it um
you know could we and then then
intelligent life evolved again on this
planet
wouldn't they want to know a lot about
us and what we knew when they wouldn't
be able to ask us
questions so one very simple thing i
said how would we archive what we know
that was a very simple idea i said you
know what that wouldn't be that hard but
a few satellites
you know going around this the sun and
we upload wikipedia every day and
um that kind of thing uh so you know we
can end up killing ourselves well it's
up there and the next intelligence piece
will find it and learn something that
would be they would like that they would
appreciate that
so that's one thing the next thing i
said well what if you know
how to outside of our solar system we
have the seti program we're looking for
these intelligent signals from everybody
and if you do a little bit of math which
i did in the book uh and you say well
what if intelligent
species only live for 10 000 years
before you know technologically
intelligent species like ones are really
able to do this
we're just starting to be able to do um
well the chances are we wouldn't be able
to see any of them because they would
have all been disappeared by
now um they would they've lived for 10
000 years and now they're gone
and so we're not going to find these
signals being sent from these people
because
i said what kind of signal could you
create that would last a million years
or a billion years
that someone would say damn it someone
smart lived there
we know that that would be a
life-changing event for us to figure
that out well what we're looking for
today in the study program isn't that
we're looking for very
coded signals in some sense and so i
asked myself what would be a different
type of signal one could create
i've always thought about this
throughout my life and in the book i
gave one
one possible suggestion which was um
we now detect planets going around other
other suns
other stars excuse me and we do that by
seeing this the
the slight dimming of the light as the
planets move in front of them that's how
we detect uh planets elsewhere in our
galaxy
um what if we created something like
that that just rotated around our
around the sun and it blocked out a
little bit of light in a particular
pattern that someone said hey
that's not a planet that is a sign that
someone was once there you can say
what if it's beating up pi you know
three point whatever
um so the idea of a distance you can
from a distance
broadly broadcast takes no continue
activation on our part this is the key
right
no one has to be seen here running a
computer and supplying it with power
it just goes on so we go it's continues
and and i argue that part of the study
program should be looking for signals
like that
and to look for signals like that you
ought to figure out what the how would
we create a signal
like what would we create that would be
like that that would persist for
millions of years
that would be broadcast broadly you
could see from a distance that was
unequivocal it came from an
uh by an intelligent species and so i
gave that one example
um because they don't know what i know
of actually and then and then finally
right if if our
ultimately our solar system will die at
some point in time
you know how do we go beyond that and i
think
it's possible if at all possible we'll
have to create intelligent machines that
travel throughout this throughout the
the solar system or throughout the
galaxy and i don't think that's going to
be humans
i don't think it's going to be
biological organisms so these are just
things to think about you know like
what's the
you know like i don't i don't want to be
like the dinosaurs i don't want to just
live and okay that was it we're done you
know
well there is a kind of presumption that
we're going to live forever which
uh i i think it is a bit sad
to imagine that the message we send as
as you talk about
is that we were once here
instead of we are here well it could be
we are still here
uh but it's more of a it's more of an
insurance policy in case we're not here
you know well i don't know but there's
something
i think about we as humans don't often
think about this but
it's like like whenever i um
[Music]
record a video i've done this a couple
times in my life i've recorded a video
for my future self just for personal
just for fun and it's always just
fascinating
to think about that preserving yourself
for future civilizations for me it was
preserving myself for future
me but that's a little that's a little
fun example
of archival these podcasts are are
preserving you and i
in a way yeah for future uh hopefully
well after we're gone but you don't
often we're sitting here talking about
this
you are not thinking about the fact that
you and i are going to die
and there will be like 10 years after
somebody watching this
and we're still alive you know in some
sense i do
i'm here because i want to talk about
ideas right and these ideas
transcend me and they transcend this
time
in on our planet um
we're talking here about ideas that
could be around a thousand years from
now or a million years from now
i when i wrote my book i had an audience
of mine
and one of the clearest audiences was
aliens
no were people reading this 100 years
from now yes
i said to myself how do i make this book
relevant to summer reading this 100
years from now what would they want to
know that we were thinking back then
what would make it
like that was an interesting it's still
an interesting book
i'm not sure i can achieve that but that
was how i thought about it because these
ideas like especially in the third part
of the book the ones we're just talking
about
you know these crazy it sounds like
crazy ideas about you know storing our
knowledge and
and you know merging our brains of
computers and sending
you know our machine down to space is
not going to happen in my lifetime
um and they may not have been happening
the next 100 years it may not happen for
a thousand years who knows
uh but we have the unique opportunity
right now
we you me and other people like this um
to
sort of at least propose the agenda
um that might impact the future like
that that's a fascinating way to think
uh both like writing or creating
try to make try to create ideas
try to create things that uh hold up in
time yeah
you know understanding how the brain
works we're gonna figure that at once
that's it it's gonna be figured out once
and after that
that's the answer and people will people
will study that
thousands of years now we still we still
you know venerate newton and einstein
and um and you know because
because ideas are exciting even well
into the future
well the interesting thing is like big
ideas even if they're wrong
are still useful like
yeah especially if they're not
completely wrong like
right newton's laws are not wrong
they're just einsteins they're
better um well it's
so yeah i mean but we're talking with
newton and einstein we're talking about
physics i wonder
if we'll ever achieve that kind of
clarity but understanding um
like complex systems and the this
particular manifestation of complex
systems which is the
human brain i'm totally optimistic we
can do that i mean
we're making progress at it i don't see
any reasons why we can't
completely i mean completely understand
in the sense um
you know we don't really completely
understand what all the molecules in
this water bottle are doing
but you know we have laws that sort of
capture it pretty good um
and uh so we'll have that kind of
understanding i mean it's not like
you're gonna have to know what every
neuron in your brain is doing um but
enough to uh
first of all to build it and second of
all to do you know
do what physics does which is like have
uh concrete experiments where we can
validate we're we're this is happening
right now like
it's not this is not some future thing
um
you know i'm very optimistic about
because i know about art our work and
what we're doing
i have to prove it to people um but um
i i consider myself a rational person
and
um you know until fairly recently i
wouldn't have said that but right now
i'm where i'm sitting right now i'm
saying you know we can this is going to
happen
there's no big obstacles to it um
we finally have a framework for
understanding what's going on in the
cortex and
um and that's liberating it's it's like
oh it's happening
so i i can't see why we wouldn't be able
to understand it i just can't
okay oh so i mean on that topic let me
ask you to play devil's advocate
is it possible for you to imagine
luck look a hundred years from now and
looking at your book
uh in which ways might your ideas be
wrong oh i worry about this all the time
um
yeah it's still useful yeah yeah
i think there's you know um well
i can i can best relate it to like
things i'm worried about right now
so we talk about this voting idea right
it's happening there's no question
that's happening
but it could be far more
[Music]
there's there's enough things i don't
know about it that it might be
working in ways differently i'm thinking
about the kind of what's voting who's
voting
you know where are representations i
talked about you have a thousand models
of a coffee cup
like that that could turn out to be
wrong
because it may be maybe there are a
thousand
models that are sub models but not
really a single model the coffee cup
um i mean there's things these are all
sort of on the edges
things that i i present as like oh it's
so simple and clean well it's not that
it's always going to be more complex
and um and there's
parts of the theory which i don't
understand the complexity well
so i think i think the idea is brain is
a distributed modeling system is
not controversial at all right that's
not that's well understood by many
people
the question then is are each quarter of
a column an independent modeling system
right um i could be wrong about that
um i don't think so but i worry about it
my intuition not even thinking why you
could be wrong
is the same intuition i have about any
sort of physicist
like strength theory that we as humans
desire for a clean explanation
and uh 100 years from now
uh intelligent systems might look back
at us and
laugh at how we try to get rid of the
whole mess
by having simple explanation when the
reality is it's
it's way messier and in fact it's
impossible to understand you can only
build it it's like this idea of complex
systems and
cellular automata yeah you can only
launch the thing you cannot understand
it
yeah i think that you know the history
of science suggests that's
not likely to occur the history of
science suggests that
look as a theorist and we're theorists
you look for simple explanations right
fully knowing that whatever simple
explanation you're going to come up with
is not going to be completely correct i
mean it can't be
i mean it's just it's just more
complexity but that's the role of
theorists play they they sort of they
give you a framework
on which you now can talk about a
problem and figure out
okay now we can start dig in more
details the best frameworks stick around
while the details change
you know again you know the classic
example is newton and einstein right you
know
um newton's theories are still used
they're still
valuable they're still practical they're
not like wrong it's just they've been
refined yeah but that's
in physics it's not obvious by the way
it's not obvious for physics either
that the universe should be such that
it's amenable to these
simple but so far it appears to be as
far as we can tell
um yeah i mean but as far as we could
tell
and but it's also an open question
whether the brain is amenable to such
clean theories that's the uh not the
brain but intelligence
well i i i don't know i would take
intelligence out of it just say you know
um well okay
um the evidence we have suggests that
the human brain
is a at the one time extremely messy and
complex but there's some parts that are
very regular and structured
that's why we started the neocortex it's
extremely regular in its structure
yeah and unbelievably so and then i
mentioned earlier the other thing is
it's it's universal abilities it is so
flexible to learn so many things we
don't
we haven't figured out what it can't
learn yet we don't know but we haven't
figured out yet but to learn things that
it never was evolved to learn
so those give us hope um that's why i
went into this field because i said you
know
this regular structure it's doing this
amazing number of things there's got to
be some underlying principles that are
that are common and other other
scientists have come up with the same
conclusions
um and so it's promising it's promising
and um and that's and whether the
theories
play out exactly this way or not that is
the role that theorists play
and so far it's worked out well even
though you know maybe
you know we don't understand all the
laws of physics but so far it's been
pretty damn useful the ones we have
are our theories are pretty bit useful
you mentioned
that uh we should not necessarily be at
least to the degree that we are
worried about the existential risks of
artificial intelligence
relative to uh human
risks from human nature being
existential risk
what aspect of human nature worries you
the most in terms of the survival of the
human species
i mean i'm disappointed in humanity as
humans i mean all of us i'm one so i'm
at disappointed myself too
it's kind of a sad state there's two
things that disappoint me
one is how it's difficult for us to
separate our rational
component of ourselves from our
evolutionary heritage which is
you know not always pretty you know
rape is a is an evolutionary good
strategy
for reproduction murder can be at times
too
you know making other people miserable
at times
is a good strategy for reproduction it's
just and it's just and
and so now that we know that and yet we
have this sort of you know we and i can
have this very rational discussion
talking about you know
intelligence and brains and life and so
on so
it seems like it's so hard it's just a
big transition to get
humans all humans to to to make the
transition from be like let's
pay no attention to all that ugly stuff
over here
let's just focus on the instances what's
unique about humanity is our knowledge
and our
intellect but the fact that we're
striving is in itself amazing right
the fact that we're able to overcome
that part and
it seems like we are more and more
becoming successful and overcoming that
that is the optimistic view and i agree
with you
yeah but i worry about it i'm not saying
i'm worrying about i think maybe that
was your question i still worry about it
yes
um you know we could be end tomorrow
because some terrorists could get
nuclear bombs and you know blow us all
up who knows
right the other thing i think i'm
disappointed is
uh and it's just i understand it it's i
guess you can't really be disappointed
it's just a fact
is that we're so prone to false beliefs
that we you know we have a model in our
head
the things we can interact with directly
physical objects
people that model is pretty good and we
can test it all the time
right i touch something i look at it i
talk to you see my model's correct
but so much of what we know is stuff i
can't directly
interact with i can't i don't know
because someone told me about it yeah
and so
so we're prone inherently prone to
having
false beliefs because if i'm told
something how am i going to know it's
right or wrong right
and so then we have the scientific
process which says
we are inherently flawed so the only way
we can
get closer to the truth is by looking
for
um contrary evidence yeah um like this
uh conspiracy theory this this theory
that scientists keep telling me about
that the earth is round
uh as far as i can tell when i look out
it looks pretty flat
yeah so yeah there is there's a tension
but it's also um
um i tend to believe that we haven't
figured out most of this thing
right most of nature around us is a
mystery
and so it um but that doesn't work does
that worry you i mean it's like oh
that's that's like a pleasure more to
figure out
right yeah that's exciting but i'm
saying like there's going to be a lot of
quote unquote wrong ideas i mean i've
been
thinking a lot about engineering systems
like social networks and so on
and i've been worried about censorship
and thinking through all that kind of
stuff because there's a lot of wrong
ideas there's a lot of dangerous ideas
but then i also read a history
read history and see when you censor
ideas that are wrong
now this could be a small-scale
censorship
like a young grad student who comes up
who like raises their hand and says some
crazy idea
yes a form of censorship could be i
shouldn't use the word censorship but
i think you may uh just like like
de-incentivize them from no no no this
is the way it's been
yeah yeah you're you're a foolish kid
don't do it yeah yeah yeah foolish uh
so in some sense uh
those wrong ideas most of the time end
up being
wrong but sometimes i agree with you so
i don't like the word censorship
um at the very end of the book i i
ended up with a sort of a a plea or a
recommended course of action and
the best way i could i know how to deal
with this issue that you bring up
is if everybody understood as part of
your
upbringing in life something about how
your brain works
that it builds a model of the world uh
how it works you know how basically
builds that model the world and that the
model
is not the real world it's just a model
and it's never going to reflect the
entire world and it can be wrong and
it's
easy to be wrong and here's all the ways
you can get the wrong model in your head
right it's not prescribed what's right
or wrong
just understand that process if we all
understood the process
then i got together and you say i
disagree with you jeff and i said lex i
disagree with you that
at least we understand that we're both
trying to model something
we both have different information which
leads to our different models
and therefore i shouldn't hold it
against you and you shouldn't hold it
against me
and we can at least agree that well what
can we look for in in
its common ground to test our our
beliefs as opposed to so much
uh as our we raise our kids on dogma
which is this is a fact and this is a
fact and these people are bad
and and you know where ever if everyone
knew just
to to be skeptical of every belief
and why and how their brains do that i
think we might have a better world
do you think the human mind is able to
comprehend
reality so you talk about sort of this
creating models that are better and
better how close do you think we get to
uh to reality there's so the wildest
ideas is like donald hoffman saying
we're very far away from reality
uh do you think we're getting close to
reality well i guess it depends on what
you define reality
uh we are getting we have a model of the
world that's very useful
right for basic well for our survival
and
our the pleasure whatever right
um so that's useful um i mean it's
really useful oh we can build planes we
can build computers we can do these
things right
uh i don't think i i don't know the
answer to that question um
i think that's part of the question
we're trying to figure out right like
you know obviously if you end up with a
theory of everything that
really is a theory of everything and all
of a sudden everything comes into play
and there's no room for something else
then you might feel like we have a good
model of the world yeah but we if we
have a theory of everything and somehow
first of all you'll never be able to
really conclusively say it's a theory of
everything but say somehow
we are very damn sure it's the theory of
everything we understand
what happened at the big bang and how
just the entirety of the physical
process i'm still not sure that
gives us an understanding of uh the next
many layers of the hierarchy yeah
abstractions that form well also what if
string theory turns out to be true
and then you say well we have no reality
no modeling what's going on in those
other dimensions that are wrapped into
it on each other
you're right or or the multiverse you
know
i i honestly don't know how for us
for human interaction for ideas of
intelligence how it helps us to
understand that we're made up of
vibrating strings that are
like tend to the whatever times smaller
than us
yeah i don't you know you could probably
build better weapons and better rockets
but you're not going to be able to
understand intelligence i guess i guess
maybe better computers no you won't be
able
i think it's just more purely knowledge
you might lead to a better
understanding of the of the beginning of
the universe
right it might lead to a better
understanding of uh
i don't know i guess i think the
acquisition of knowledge has always been
one where
you you pursue it for its own pleasure
um and you don't always know what is
going to make a difference
yeah you're pleasantly surprised by the
the weird things you find
do you think uh for the for the
neocortex in general
do you think there's a lot of innovation
to be done on the machine
side you know you use the computer as a
metaphor
quite a bit is there a different types
of computer that would help us build i
mean what are the intelligences like the
manifestations of intelligent machines
yeah or is it oh no it's going to be
totally
crazy uh we have no idea how this is
going to look out yet
but you can already see this today we of
course remodel these things on
traditional computers and now now gpus
are really popular with
with you know neural networks and so on
um
but there are companies coming up with
fundamentally new physical substrates
that are just really cool i don't know
if they're going to work or not
but i think there'll be decades of
innovation here
yeah totally do you think the final
thing will
be messy like our biology is messy or do
you think
um it's it's the it's the old bird
versus airplane question
or do you think we could just uh
build airplanes yeah that
that fly way better than birds in the
same way we can build
uh uh electrical and
yeah yeah you know can i can i can i
refund the bird thing a bit because i
think it's interesting
people ability misunderstand this the
wright brothers
um the problem they were trying to solve
was controlled flight
how to turn an airplane not how to
propel an airplane
they weren't worried about that
interesting yeah they already had at
that time
there was already wing shapes which they
had from studying birds there was
already gliders that carry people
the problem is if you put a rudder on
the back of a glider and you turn it the
plane falls out of the sky
so the problem was how do you control
flight and
they studied birds and they actually had
birds in captivity they watched birds in
wind tunnels
they observed in the wild and they
discovered the secret was the birds
twist their wings
when they turn and so that's what they
did on the wright brothers flyer they
had these
sticks you would twist the wing and that
was that was their innovation
not their propeller and today airplanes
still twist their wings we don't twist
the entire wing we just just the tail
end of it
the the the flaps which is the same
thing so today's airplanes fly on the
same principles as
birds which is observed by so everyone
get that analogy wrong
but let's step back from that right once
you understand
the principles of flight you can choose
how to implement them yeah
no one's going to use bones and feathers
and muscles
um but they do have wings and uh we
don't flap them we have propellers so
when we have the principles
of of computation that goes on to
modeling the world in the brain we
understand those principles very clearly
we have choices on how to implement them
and some of them will be biologically
like and some won't
and um but i do think there's going to
be a huge amount of innovation here
just think about the innovation we're in
the computers they had to invent the the
transistor they invented the the silicon
ship
they had the invent you know then this
software i mean
zillions of things they had to do memory
systems um we're gonna do
it's gonna be similar well it's
interesting that the deep
learning um the effectiveness of deep
learning for
a specific task is driving a lot of
innovation in the hardware
which may have effects for uh
actually allowing us to discover
intelligent systems that operate very
differently
or that's much bigger than deep learning
yeah interesting so
ultimately it's good to have an
application that's making our life
better now
because the the the capitalist process
if you can make money
yeah yeah that works i mean the other
way i mean
neil degrasse tyson writes about this is
the other way we fund science of course
is through military
so like yeah uh conquest so here here's
an interesting thing we're doing on this
regard
so we've decided we we used to have a
series these biological principles and
we can see how to build these
intelligent machines
but we've decided to apply some of these
principles to today's machine learning
techniques
so uh one of the we didn't talk about
this principle one is uh
sparsity in the brain um most of the
neurons are active at any point in time
as far as and the connectivity is sparse
and that's different than deep learning
networks
um so we've already shown that we can
speed up existing deep learning networks
uh anywhere from 10 to a factor of 100
i mean literally 100 and make it more
robust
at the same time so this is commercially
very very valuable
um and so you know if we can prove this
actually in the larger systems that are
commercially applied today
there's a big commercial desire to do
this well
sparsity is something that doesn't run
really well on existing hardware it
doesn't really run really well
on gpus um and on cpus
and so that would be a way of sort of
bringing more and
more brain principles into the existing
system on a on a commercially valuable
basis
another thing we can think we can do is
we're going to use the dendrites
models of we i talked earlier about the
the prediction occurring inside of
neuron that that basic property can be
applied to
existing neural networks and allow them
to learn continuously which something
they don't do today
and so yeah well
we wouldn't model this spikes but the
idea that you have that
neuro today's neural networks have
something called the point neuron which
is a very simple model of a neuron
and uh by adding dendrites to them with
just one more level of complexity
that's in biological systems you can
solve problems in continuous learning
um and rapid learning so we're trying to
take
we're trying to bring the existing field
and we'll see if we can do it we're
trying to bring the existing field of
machine learning
commercially along with us you brought
up this idea of keeping you know paying
for it
commercially along with us as we move
towards the ultimate goal of a true ai
system
even small innovations on neural
networks are really really exciting
yeah because it seems like such a
trivial model
of the brain and applying different
insights
that just even like you said continuous
uh learning
or uh making it more asynchronous
or maybe making more dynamic or
like uh incentivizing making it fast
even just from robots
and making it somehow much better
incentivizing sparsity uh somehow yeah
uh well if you can make things 100 times
faster then there's plenty of incentive
people people spending millions of
dollars you know just training some of
these networks now these
uh these transformer networks let me ask
you a big question
how for young people uh listening to
this today
in high school and college what advice
would you give them
in terms of uh which career path to take
and um maybe just about life in general
well in my case um
i didn't start life with any kind of
goals i was when i was going to college
i was like oh what did i say well maybe
i'll do
electrical engineering stuff you know um
it wasn't like you know today you see
some of these young kids are so
motivated they're going to change the
world i was like
you know whatever and um
but then i did fall in love with
something besides my wife but i fell in
love with this like oh my god it would
be so cool to understand how the brain
works
and then i i said to myself that's the
most important thing i could work on
i i can't imagine anything more
important because if we understand how
brains work you'd build telescope
machines and they could figure out
all the other big questions of the world
right so and then i said
i want to understand how i work so i
fell in love with this idea and i became
passionate about it
and this is you know a trope people say
this but it was
it's true because i was passionate about
it
i was able to put up almost so much crap
you know you know i was i was in that
you know i was like
person said you can't do this i was i
was a graduate student at berkeley when
they said you can't study this problem
you know no one's gonna solve this or
you can't get funded for it you know
then i went to do you know mobile
computing and it was like people say you
can't do that you can't build a cell
phone
you know so but all along i kept being
motivated because i wanted to work on
this problem i said i want to understand
the brain works and if i got myself male
i got one lifetime i'm gonna figure it
out
do the best i can so by having that
because you know these it's really as
you point out lex it's really hard to
do these things people it's just there's
so many downers along the way
so many ways obstacles are getting your
way yeah i'm sitting here happy all the
time but trust me
it's not always like that that's i guess
the the happiness that the
the passion is a prerequisite for
surviving the whole
yeah i think so i think that's right um
and
so i i don't want to sit to someone and
say you know you need to find a passion
and do it no maybe you don't
but if you do find something you're
passionate about
then then you can follow it as far as
your passion will
let you put up with it do you remember
how you found it this is
how the spark happened
why specifically for me yeah like
because you said it's
such an interesting so like almost like
later in life by later i mean like not
in
when you were five yeah you you didn't
really know
and then all of a sudden you fell in
love with that yeah yeah there was there
was
there's two separate events that
compounded one another one
when i was probably a teenager might
have been 17 or 18.
i made a list of the most interesting
problems i could think of
first was why does the universe exist it
seems like not existing is more likely
yeah the second one was well given
exists why does it behave the way it
does
you know it's laws of physics y is equal
to m c squared not m c cubed you know
attention question i don't know
third one was like what's the origin of
life um
and the fourth one was what's
intelligence and i stopped there
i said well that's probably the most
interesting one and i put that aside
um as a teenager but then when i was 22
and i was reading the um no it was
excuse me i was 70 it was 1979 excuse me
i was reading uh so i was at that time i
was 22.
i was reading uh the september issue of
scientific american which is all about
the brain
and then the final essay was by francis
crick
who of dna fame and he had
taken his interest to studying the brain
now and he said you know
there's something wrong here he says we
got all this data
oh this fact this is 1979 all these
facts about the brain tons and tons of
facts about the brain
do we need more facts or do we just need
to think about a way of rearranging the
facts we have maybe we're just not
thinking about the problem correctly
you know because he says this shouldn't
be
it shouldn't be like this you know so i
read that and i said wow
i said i don't have to become like an
experimental neuroscientist
i could just look at all those facts and
try to
and become a theoretician and try to
figure it out
and i said that i felt like it was
something i would be good at
i said i wouldn't be a good
experimentalist i don't have the
patience for it
but i'm a good thinker and i love
puzzles
and this is like the biggest puzzle in
the world it's the biggest puzzle of all
time
and i got all the puzzle pieces in front
of me damn that was exciting
and there's something obviously you
can't convert it towards it just kind of
sparked
this passion and i have that a few times
in my life just something
um yeah just just like you uh
it grabs you yeah i thought it was
something that was both important
that i could make a contribution to yeah
and so all of a sudden it felt like
oh it gave me purpose in life yeah you
know i honestly don't think it has to be
as big as one of those four questions
no no i think you can find those things
in in the smallest
oh absolutely i'm with uh david foster
wallace said like the key to life is to
be unborable i'm
i think i think it's very possible to
find that
intensity of joy in the smallest
absolutely i'm just you asked me my
story
yeah yeah i'm actually speaking to the
audience yeah it doesn't have to be
those four
you happen to get excited by one of the
bigger questions of
in the universe but uh but that even the
smallest things and watching the
olympics now
just uh just giving yourself life uh
giving your life over to the study and
the mastery of a particular sport is
fascinating
and and uh if if it sparks
joy and passion you're able to in the
case of the olympics
basically suffer for like a couple of
decades to achieve i mean you can find
joint passion just being a parent i mean
yeah yeah the the parenting one is funny
so i always
uh not always but for a long time wanted
kids and
get married and stuff and especially
that has to do with the fact that
i've seen a lot of people that i respect
get a whole other level of joy from kids
and you know at first is like
your thinking is well like i don't have
enough time in the day
right if i have this passion which is
true
yes but like if i want to solve
intelligence how is this
kids situation gonna help me but then
you realize
that uh
you know like you said the things that
sparks joy and it's very possible that
kids can provide even a greater or
deeper more meaningful
joy than those bigger questions yeah
when they they enrich each other and
that that seemed like um
obviously when i was younger it's
probably a counter-intuitive notion
because there's only so many hours in
the day
but then life is finite and you have to
pick the things that give
give you joy yeah but you know also
you understand you you can be patient
too i mean it's finite
but we do have you know whatever 50
years or so it's not so long yeah
so so in my case you know in my case i
had to give up on my dream of the
neuroscience
because i i was a graduate student at
berkeley and they told me i couldn't do
this and i couldn't get funded and
you know and and so i went back in
and went back in the computing industry
for a number of years i thought it would
be four but it turned out to be more
but i said but i said i'll come back you
know i definitely i'm definitely gonna
come back i know i'm gonna do this
computer stuff for a while but i'm
definitely coming back everyone knows
that
and it's they moved like raising kids
well yeah you still you have to spend a
lot of time with your kids it's fun
enjoyable um but that doesn't mean
you have to give up on other dreams it
just means that you may have to wait a
week or two
to work on that next idea well
you talked about the the the darker side
of me disappointing sides of human
nature that we're
hoping to overcome so that we don't
destroy ourselves i tend to
put a lot of value in um the broad
general concept of love
of uh the human capacity to um
of compassion towards each other of just
kindness whatever that longing of like
just the human
human to human connection yeah it
connects back to our initial discussion
i tend to see a lot of value in this
collective intelligence aspect
i think some of the magic of human
civilization happens when there's
uh a party is not as fun when it you're
alone yeah
i totally agree with you on these issues
uh do you think
from a neurocortex perspective
uh what role does love play in the human
condition uh well those are two separate
things from a new project
i don't think it doesn't impact our
thinking about human uh about the
neocortex
from a human condition point of view i
think it's core um
i mean we get so much pleasure out of
loving people
and helping people um
so you know i can i'll rack it up to old
brain stuff and maybe you can throw it
under the
the bust of evolution if you want um
that's fine
um uh it doesn't impact how i think
about how we model the world
but from a humanity point of view i
think it's essential well i tend to
give it to the new brain and also i tend
to think that some of aspects
of that need to be engineered into ai
systems
both in their ability to have compassion
for other humans
and their ability to
maximize love in the world between
humans
so i'm more thinking about the social
network so like
whenever there's a deep integration
between ai systems and humans
so specific applications where it's uh
ai
and humans i think that's something that
often not talked about in terms of um
metrics over which you try to maximize
uh like which metric to maximize in a
system
it seems like one of the most powerful
things in societies
is the capacity to work it's fascinating
i think it's
it's a great way of thinking about it
you know i have
i have been thinking more of these
fundamental mechanisms in the brain as
opposed to
the social interaction between the
interaction between humans and ai
systems in the future which is
and i think if you think about that
you're absolutely right um
but that's that's a complex system i can
have intelligent systems that don't have
that component but they're not
interacting with people you know they're
just running something or building a
building someplace or something i don't
know um
but if you think about interacting with
humans yeah it's it's gonna
and then but it has to be engineered in
there i don't think it's gonna appear on
its own
uh that's a good question i yeah well we
could
in terms of uh uh from a reinforcement
learning perspective
whether the darker sides of human nature
or the better angels of our nature
uh win out yeah statistically speaking i
don't know
i tend to be optimistic and hope that
love wins out in the end
um you've done a lot of incredible stuff
and your book is uh
driving towards this fourth question
that you started with
on the nature of intelligence what do
you hope your
legacy for people reading a hundred
years from now
how do you hope they remember your work
how do you hope they remember this book
well i think as an entrepreneur or
scientist or
any human who's trying to accomplish
some things i have a view that
really all you can do is accelerate the
inevitable
um yeah it's like you know if we didn't
figure out if we didn't study the brain
someone else would study the brain if
you know if elon just
didn't make electric cars someone else
would do it eventually and if you know
if thomas anderson didn't invent a light
bulb we wouldn't be using candles today
so what you can do as an individual is
you can accelerate
something that's beneficial and make it
happen sooner than whatever that's
that's really it that's all you can do
um you can't create a new reality that
it wasn't gonna happen
um so from that perspective
um i would hope that our work not just
me but our work
in general um people would look back and
said
hey they really helped make this better
future happen sooner
um they you know they helped us
understand the nature of false beliefs
sooner than we met up they made it
now we're so happy that we have these
intelligent machines doing these things
helping us
that that maybe that solved the climate
change problem and
they made it happen sooner so i think
that's the best
i would hope for some would say those
guys just
moved the needle forward a little bit in
time well
i do it it feels like the progress of
human civilization is not
is uh there's a lot of trajectories and
if you have individuals that accelerate
towards one direction that helps steer
human civilization so
i think in this long stretch of time all
all trajectories will be traveled but i
think it's nice
for this particular civilization on
earth to travel down one that's not yeah
well i think you're right i mean look we
have the
take the whole period of you know world
war ii nazism or something like that
well that was a bad sidestep right
went over there for a while but you know
there is the optimistic view about life
that
um that ultimately it does converge in a
positive way
it progresses ultimately even if we have
years of
darkness um so yeah so i think you can
perhaps
that's accelerating the positive it
could also mean eliminating some bad
missteps along the way too um
but but i i'm an optimistic in that way
i was like you know despite we talked
about the end of civilization
you know i i think we're gonna live for
a long time i hope we are
um i think our society in the future is
gonna be better we're gonna have less
discord we're gonna have less people
killing each other you know we'll solve
you know we'll make the
they'll live in some sort of way that's
compatible with the carrying capacity of
the earth
um i'm optimistic these things will
happen
and all we can do is try to get there
sooner and at the very least if we do
destroy ourselves we'll have a few
satellites
i will uh that will tell alien
civilization that we
were once or maybe our future you know
future inhabitants of earth you know
imagine you know
the planet of the apes scenario you know
we kill ourselves in a you know million
years from now or billion years from now
there's another species on the planet
curious creatures were once here yeah um
jeff
thank you so much for your work and um
thank you so much for talking to me once
again
well it's great i love what you do i
love your podcast you have the most
interesting people
me aside so
it's a real service i think you do for
uh a very broader sense for humanity i
think
thanks jeff all right pleasure thanks
for listening to this conversation with
jeff hawkins
and thank you to codeacademy bio
optimizers
expressvpn asleep and blinkist
check them out in the description to
support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from albert camus
an intellectual is someone whose mind
watches
itself i like this because i'm happy to
be both haves
the watcher and the watched can they be
brought together
this is a practical question we must try
to answer
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you